all we hope is that you will not see
what the Blood Red Sky kishar saw as he
ran through the streets all around him
were the sounds of violence women
screaming as their babies were stolen
from their arms axes swung towards men
who were just trying to protect their
families kar's sandals fell apart as he
ran the leather falling from his feet as
the hard Stones drew blood all around
him was red the blood from his feet the
burning buildings and of course the
cursed sky above his head Kar ran out
through the gates of the city and Into
the Wilderness looking back over his
shoulder he saw smoke engulfing the
skies above it all stood the Tower of
Babel a shadow hidden in Smoke Beneath
The Blood Red Sky what had once been a
source of Refuge hope and wisdom for
kishar now looked like the arrival of
Hell on Earth the Persian army swarmed
around the city like ants blowing holes
in the city walls and torching house
after house arrows flew with total
abandon he wasn't sure if they were even
being fired at anyone in particular all
night he had been waiting for one of
them to Lodge itself between his
shoulder blades but somehow he had
survived Kar ran through the desert
until his legs gave out on him he lay on
his back staring up at the night sky no
longer was it just red but purple and
blacks and blues and colors he'd never
even seen before things his eyes didn't
quite understand as much as he had been
afraid of the Persian army a new fear
crept into his stomach one deeper and
more Primal it wasn't just the Persian
army who were bringing judgment to his
people it was God himself fear pushing
him to keep going the armies would find
him within a day if he stopped here he
needed to hide to find somewhere safe
that he could spend the night on the
horizon was a rocky outcrop there must
be a cave in there somewhere there had
to be an hour later kesar stumbled
through the Rocks leaving bloody
Footprints with every step his mouth was
horar and dry his legs burned and
wobbled barely capable of supporting his
weight anymore Stop The Voice echoed
between the cliffs becoming so loud that
kishar believed he truly found God but
it was a man or rather
a group of men dressed in black and
white robes that were standing at the
entrance to a cave they were
well-dressed looked well fed and clean
perhaps they could help him unable to
speak he MiniMed desperately for water
as he collapsed on the ground at their
feet but all that he was met with was a
jab from one of their staffs wincing
kishar rolled onto his back and
whispered his pleas up at them all that
the man told him was that he was to go
far far away from this place and forget
he had ever seen it kesar tried to
explain that the Persian army had
invaded Babylon had fallen and that it
was all over but the man just carried on
Staring at him seemingly unfaced by what
he told them one of them looked up at
the sky at the dark swirling colors and
gestured to the others come we must
return inside the sky is worse than I
feared Driven Crazy by desperation
kashar pushed himself to his feet barged
his way past the men and sprinted into
the cave his foot caught a rock and he
went tumbling rolling down down down
along a slope that led deep into the
Earth behind him he could hear the men
shouting and chasing all he needed was a
drink he would take their water endure
their beating and be on his way but he
looked up his blood ran cold he was not
alone in this cave there suspended in
front of him was a kind of ball it was
slightly larger than he was and hung in
the air without anything to support it
his eyes could not make sense of what
they were seeing the ball shimmered like
shallow water being agitated by
someone's hand it was black and white
the colors fighting against each other
like droplets of rain that were thrown
around by the wind but at the same time
it wasn't those things he could see
through it slightly he could see the
other wall of the cave kishar stood up
and slowly crept around the the side of
the ball not even noticing the voices of
the men crying louder in his ears
looking through it was though the world
was bent out of shape flickering and
jutting with energy he reached out a
curious hand what will it feel like to
touch the thing to feel a miracle with
his hand his trembling fingers crept
closer and closer to the edge of the orb
he took a breath and plunged his arm
inside immediately pain like he had
never experienced shot through his body
and that was when he saw it on the other
side of the orb standing with its back
pressed against the wall of the cave was
something so horrific that the air left
his lungs thrashing and screaming by the
time the men reached the cave kishar had
collapsed on the floor he died soon
after as two of the men went about
carrying his body back out of the cave
another sat quietly in the corner with
the Epic of gilgames open on his lap
reading in a calm voice
and watching as over in the corner of
the room the orb gradually shrunk in
size if at any point the sky begins to
change color without any stimuli or
obvious explanation as to why it's
happening all Foundation members are
immediately to go into alert level 7 all
Personnel stationed at sites 05 and 06
to go into alert level 8 and immediately
began to prepare new methods for
containing SCP
001 site 5 has has been constructed
around Point Alpha the place where all
of this begins Point Alpha is believed
to have existed for thousands of years
the earliest known records of its
existence come from the Babylonian
Empire a number of manuscripts make
reference to the existence of this cave
and a group of sages known as the order
of white and black it was their duty to
patrol the cave and protected from
anyone discovering what was hidden
inside at the fall of the Babylonian
Empire as the Arham Ed Persians invaded
this order was replaced by a group of
Zer roian monks of whom there are few
written records much of their history
was passed down orally the most
substantial account that the foundation
has to date comes from the ancient Greek
philosopher Zer who made an expedition
into the ainan Empire and found Point
Alpha unlike most who came before him
the monks walked amzer into the cave
with open arms he had spent years
traveling deepening his understanding of
philosophy and culture he was a great
lover of literature and early on in his
travels he acquired so many manuscripts
he had been forced to purchase a camel
just so that he could take them all with
him traveling from town to town he had
collected story after Story myth after
myth from all the local peoples with the
goal of finding what it was that unified
Humanity across cultures races and
religions it was because of his camel
that the monks were so happy to see him
they rushed him inside and almost
immediately began to unpack his things
and lay them out in a special chamber
that they had dug into the cave walls
all night they prepared extravagant food
for him slaughtering a goat and
preparing it over the open flames in
celebration it was only once he was well
rested they introduced him to what was
housed deeper in the cave Zera had the
same fearful reaction that kishar had
centuries before only he had the common
sense not to put his hand into the ball
but the Stillness of the monks around
him helped to put him at ease they
calmly explained to him that it was his
turn to read a story and that he may
pick any Tales he liked from his
collection of manuscripts they beckoned
him over to a cushion on one side of the
cave where he knelt and began to read as
he did so he saw the creature inside the
orb for the first time it skirted around
the opposite wall of the cave and peered
at him with a look something like
curiosity the creature wasn't a human
that much was apparent it was emaciated
like many of the children that he had
seen on his travels but unlike them it
was enormous its hunch figure seemed to
fill up the cave and in another way
seemed to be Beyond The Cave somehow his
eyes couldn't quite make sense of what
they were seeing but as he he read the
creature seemed to find contentment it
was very still and very focused on his
words he wondered if it could even
understand what he was saying so he
paused and decided to ask it that
question almost immediately the creature
began to thrash its way and that either
Agony or rage distorted its face zero
tried to calm it down to talk gently to
it to reassure that everything was okay
but nothing made a difference the sphere
itself started to pulse and grow larger
Rippling and shaking with energy the
monks yelled at him to continue reading
and he did so no sooner had he read the
next sentence than the creature seemed
to calm and the sphere began to shrink
again how interesting all told zero
spent 7 months living in the cave with
the monks he exhausted all of the
literature that he had brought with him
while making sure to write detailed
notes every evening about what he had
witnessed and what he had learned
firstly it seemed as if the creatur did
understand him because when he read
stories that were of higher quality with
more interesting characters and greater
Stakes it seemed to be calmer and more
interested in what he had to say the
weaker stories that he had picked up
local folklore and cautionary tales had
less of an effect and the creatures
seemed closer to agitation as he read
them on a number of occasions he had
been forced to abandon the story early
in favor of a better one as the creature
on the other side of the orb seemed to
run out of patience for what he was
saying yet it would not speak back to
him he heard no voice and saw no
attempts from this creature to
communicate with him in any way it did
not seem to build any kind of emotional
connection with him it did not matter
whether he was reading or one of the
monks was all the creature seemed to
care about was the quality of what was
being read to it apparently that was
what all the monks cared about as well
as soon as Zur had run out of
manuscripts to read to the creature he
was escorted out of the the cave and
sent on his way without so much as a
loaf of bread following the conquest of
Alexander the Great po Alpha was once
again claimed by a different
civilization en raptured by the writings
of Zer Alexander had made a specific
point to conquer this region he
established his own order known as the
Kronos guard to whom he gave a selection
of the finest Greek epics to read inside
the cave it was their belief that they
had found Kronos and were punishing him
by reading these Tales the group stood
throughout the rise of the sasanid
empire and even the formation of the
rashan califate before eventually being
replaced by an Islamic equivalent named
the society for the containment of the
Babel demon presently po Alpha is under
the control of the SCP Foundation the
cushion and the monk in the corner have
been replaced by a speaker about 5 m
away from the anomaly herein referred to
as SCP 00 1-1 whatever it is that is
living inside or on the other side of
the sphere is referred to as SCP 00 1-2
the speaker that reads into it is run
from a series of backup generators so
that at no point will there be a break
in the flow of literature the speaker is
connected directly to site 06 and the
scip net database due to the inherent
danger of close proximity to SCP
0011 no Personnel are authorized to
visit Point Alpha anymore anything that
comes into physical contact with SCP 001
D2 is immediately turned into Argon gas
it is the foundation's goal through
Reading literature to keep SCP 001 D2
entertained at all times if at any point
the literature stops or SCP 001 D2 is
not satisfied by the quality of what is
being read to it
scp1 will occur this refers to the event
where SCP 00 1-1 starts to EXP expand
and the sky spontaneously changes color
initially turning blood red if not
rapidly controlled this soon constitutes
a reality breakdown event natural
disasters begin to happen all throughout
the world and in various places reality
itself starts to fall apart it goes
without saying this is not ideal in
order for Humanity to survive and
perhaps the universe itself to continue
it is of utmost importance that SCP 001
2 receives constant highquality
Entertainment Security classification of
this SCP was temporarily lowered so that
all level two Personnel would have
access to the file and the ability to
suggest Solutions one of the first
suggestions that was raised was the idea
of using artificial intelligence to
constantly generate story content to be
read over the speaker this suggestion
was approved and quickly put into
practice but almost immediately SCP 0012
began to thrash violently
and SCP 0011 rapidly expanded this led
directly to a currently redacted natural
disaster on the other side of the world
in the mid 2000s another suggestion was
that the foundation employ a team of the
world's best authors and writers to
continually pen stories to satisfy the
creature the suggestion was denied as
historical documentation has proven time
and time again that SCP 00 1-2 does not
respond well to literature that has been
written specifically for it the stories
must be organic and serve a greater
purpose a recent Containment Breach
pushed the foundation to start
experimenting with methods that they had
previously denied the most important of
these was the reading of a main lless
document from the SCP Foundation itself
to the creature previously the
suggestion had been shut down as it
would constitute an information leak but
desperation led the foundation to try
reading one of the accounts of a
different SCP to it this was an
overwhelming success the SCP document
was able to be read over 14 times before
SCP 000012 got bored of hearing it off
the back of this trial the foundation
approved the declassification of a
number of SCP main lless documents to be
read to
scp-2 at first there were only 999 scps
that could be read to it but as the
foundation crept towards running out of
numbers they decided to expand Beyond
999 9 scps up to
7,999 as of right now this is where the
total sits but the foundation may be
forced in the future to expand even
beyond that number most interestingly of
all the foundation seems to have
stumbled upon a more permanent solution
the creation as a file describing SCP
001 itself perhaps even in the form of
an animated video SCP 00 1-2 seems to
demonstrate a level of enjoyment for
stories that mention itself but the
added layer suggested by the foundation
member was that this animated video
could be recursive like the images you
see zooming closer and closer and closer
without ever really stopping or getting
any closer to a conclusion a video that
could be cyclical and start itself again
so that the story would never cease
after all all we hope is that you will
never see the Blood Red Sky kishar saw
as he ran through the streets all around
him were the sounds of violence women
screaming as their babies were stolen
from their arms axes swung towards men
who were just trying to protect their
families Kar sandals fell apart as he
ran the leather falling from his feet as
the hard Stones drew blood all around
him was red while some higher level
researchers specialized guards and
containment experts at the SCP
Foundation have fixed anomalous projects
tailored to their very particular set of
skills for many lower level operatives
including Junior researchers guards
janitorial staff and even the dreaded D
classes every day is showing up spinning
the wheel of Misfortune and finding out
how you might die today will you be
hacked to Pieces by a murder monster
pulled into a portal turned into a doll
eaten alive made into a living Nest by
bugs stretched out and broken drowned
exanguination set on fire beaten to
death by a volley of anomalous tomatoes
because you decided to drop a
cringeworthy dad joke or a rancid pun
there are perhaps only a handful of
anomalies that not only will not harm
you but will actively enrich your life
by getting to spend time with them and
of course Chief among these is the
legendary SCP 999 also known by its
adorable moniker the Tickle Monster we
don't need to get into too much detail
in describing this gelatinous ray of
sunshine his anomalous delightfulness
has made him somewhat of a celebrity
compared to the murderer's row of
terrifying entities and monsters around
him the researcher assigned to him today
was troubled having seen one of his
favorite co-workers devoured by SCP 682
the day before getting assigned to
feeding and checking on scp-999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of M&M's in hand
the creature CED perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be all right for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured
M&M's into its eager mouth radiating
Good Vibes the whole time what an asset
what a gift and to think this adorable
little goober was prophesized to someday
save the world that much seemed almost
funny but he was certainly more than
capable of saving the life of someone
who hadn't felt the warmth of internal
sunshine in quite some time and for that
much the researcher was profoundly
grateful he left 99's chamber that day
with a renewed sense of hope for the
future that maybe just maybe they might
be able to pull through to make a
difference to push this crazy ball of
rock we call our home in the right
direction maybe someday the Sun would
rise on a perfect world who would have
thought that a strange Sunrise could
change everything emergency Sirens went
off across the globe but in every case
they were drowned out by a terrible
endless chorus of Screams but below all
that you'll hear another gut-wrenching
sound a low but pervasive sizzling like
an egg on a hot pan as billions of human
beings started to change their states of
matter the SCP Foundation had fought off
and contained so many seemingly
impossible threats from interdimensional
Horrors like the hanged sealed and
Scarlet Kings to nightmarish Mass
Killers like SCP 106 the old man scp096
the Shy Guy and SCP 682 the hardto
destroy reptile in their many battles
against the anomalous they developed the
incredible methodologies and exceedingly
advanced technology but what good would
any of it do when the very center of our
solar system decided in an instant that
rather being the Lynch pin of our
delicate cradle of life it would instead
be the horrible instrument of all of our
demises this awful hypothetical was Ed
upon the emergence of SCP 001 a terrible
day also known as when day breaks in the
snap of one's fingers half the world was
plunged into Terror and death rays of
Stark red light swept through the
streets people lucky enough to be in the
shade or inside buildings with a view to
the outside saw the people in the
streets seize up and begin to shriek in
terrible pain their skin sagged and
their bones liquefied their bodies
dropped down to the ground and coalesced
into gurgling wretching Puddles the
color of melted flesh those who saw this
Abomination happening would never forget
it it would stay with them for the rest
of their lives it would endure like a
stain on their retinas and after image
burned into the plasma of an old TV
screen but here's a slight consolation
for most of the human race the rest of
their lives wouldn't be that long the
sudden Insanity taking over the world
caused the SCP Foundation to do
something drastic step out of the
Shadows metaphorically speaking of
course the legendary Foundation motto
had been reversed they would die in the
light so that Humanity could live on in
the dark thankfully the very concept of
the day gave them one advantage while
one side of the Earth was effectively
doomed the second the process began the
other side had a 12-hour Head Start
before the sun turned its terrible eye
to them sirens went off in the middle of
the night w waking people up groggy
rubbing the sleep from their eyes every
television and radio and internet
enabled device in their home was playing
the same message direct from the SCP
Foundation which now had effectively
commandeered the entire US Government
along with the rest of the world it gave
them directions to the nearest
Foundation containment site and told
them that if they didn't immediately
comply and find their way to safety they
would experience a terrible death by
sunrise and if you're at all familiar
with human beings you've probably
already predicted that they didn't just
calmly wrap themselves up make their way
to their cars and form an orderly line
to the various Foundation containment
sites located around them it was in fact
total pandemonium as the solar clock
ticked down slowly marking off the
seconds that anyone outside had left to
live the only human beings with a
meaningful Head Start began to go insane
in a number of varied and interesting
ways some who took the situation
seriously and acknowledged that the Sun
was indeed going to wipe out most of
humanity simply cracked under the
pressure there were those who went into
totally catatonic States rocking back
and forth in the corner and refusing to
respond to any stimuli some became
erratic and violent with unpredictable
behavior that harmed themselves and
others after all what was the point in
acting normally anymore when the
complete crumbling of human civilization
was imminent and their only hope was
some shadowy organization they'd never
heard of some not heeding the morning
seriously enough and prompted by greed
and opportunism tried to take advantage
of the situation financially some
smashed Windows of local stores and
looted or broke into the homes of
neighbors who had already fled in hopes
of plowing their property others were a
little more creative setting up
shortterm everything must go nighttime
fire sales for their brands of essential
oils neotropics and neutraceuticals
claiming all of them had the power to
ward off or cure the new effects of the
sun others completely denied the
possibility that any of this was real
and claimed that the messages from the
so-called SCP Foundation were actually
just a front to take away their freedoms
and trap them in underground government
camps they staunchly refused to follow
any of the safety guidelines that the
SCP Foundation put out claiming if you
try to take away my first amendment
rights you're going to take away my
second amendment rights while riding
around in their pickup trucks and SUVs
blasting Kid Rocks don't tell me how to
live at earsplitting volume
naturally they had all melted into
screeching puddles of liquid flesh by
Sunrise some were not victims of their
own bizarre choices but were doomed by
the sudden terrible fear and panic of
the circumstances themselves the
highways were gridlocked cars stuck as
far as the eye could see so many had
rushed to escape during the initial wave
that means of Transport soon became
choke points like clogged arteries in a
dying man people do irrational things
when they're scared riots broke out in
the streets fighting killing burning
everyone hoping for some means of meager
control over a situation that had long
been out of any of their hands some were
too far away with not enough time to
close the distance what could they
really do but just sit around and wait
to die the hours marched on as the earth
made its slow turn towards the sun
leaving one decimated half in darkness
and the other a Sitting Duck for its
terrible effects hundreds of thousands
had made their way to the containment
site and safely gotten inside but still
so many millions were left outside it
was a slaughterhouse one great big
Global meat grinder and every moment
that passed the handle turned and any
humans left outside got just that little
bit closer to the grinding nashing gears
below site 19 being the largest
containment site on the foundation books
also became Humanity's only Bastion it
was the great hope of escape from the
horrors going on outside the foundation
had figured out so many ways of
counteracting deadly anomalous forces
before given enough time and enough
Personnel surely they could figure out a
solution to even this this was however
when the most startling realization yet
swept over all the survivors those who
were melted by the sudden hostile Sun
weren't dead they were very much alive
in fact but they'd been changed in both
body and mind what had once been humans
now became terrible beasts half melted
gelatinous nightmares that coagulated
into even bigger beasts they got into
their head that they were grateful for
the transformation that they had been
liberated from their old forms in the
old world they were something so much
more now and they wanted everyone else
to join them in their Liberation
survivors outside the foundation
containment sites were systematically
hunted by these great masses of altered
flesh even though smart enough to cover
every inch of their bodies with clothes
to protect from the Sun to only move at
night to carry weapons were dragged out
by meaty tendrils from their refuge in
the basements and the lightless hearts
of buildings dragged into the Searing
gaze of the sun to melt to change to
coales into something greater it was the
inevitable fate of all of humanity when
most of the stragglers were dragged out
and changed the flesh masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor diluted people
from salvation they mounted a defensives
against the bases which the foundation
with what remained of their Manpower and
advanced Weaponry did what they could to
repel the attacks but every single day
it got harder thankfully for the people
H up at site 19 there was one
consolation out there to help SCP 999
the foundation was at war with the sun
and its terrible disciples and contrary
to many people's beliefs it takes more
than men equipment and bullets to win a
war 999 provided the essential element
that brought it all together morale hope
the will to go on even when it seemed
like all could be lost after a long day
of battling the fleshy Abominations At
The Gates Foundation guards mobile task
force members and even civilian
volunteers were drained and traumatized
by the horrors that they'd seen once a
day was over 999 would move among the
ranks cuddling up to them warding off
the despair that was easy to set in
during the downswing of a terrible
apocalypse like this without his
presence there would be no hope of
fighting that good fight so many of them
would have given up walked into the Sun
and joined the Monstrous Force they were
fighting after all they seemed happy
enough and it would certainly be easier
999 had become once again an
indispensable asset to the SCP
Foundation the solar betrayal may not
have been the Scarlet kings's doing well
as far as our current Intel suggests
anyway but he was playing a crucial part
in Saving the world exactly as predicted
999 didn't fully understand what was
going on outside sometimes why there
seemed to be fewer people as the weeks
went on and why the people there seemed
so sad all the time whenever he wasn't
helping them but he was more than happy
to help whatever the case many of the
humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically posed no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment Chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated Chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom had lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
horrors out there 999 made the rounds in
these areas regularly and through the
d-class cots which had been repurposed
into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from from them for all
these years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in Dark Times slithering from
person to person giving hope where there
was none people opened up about their
problems and their fears which these
days were remarkably similar and though
999 couldn't reply for many was enough
just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft Blobby
shoulder to cry on and after day broke
everyone needed a good old-fashioned cry
however one day while wandering The Long
Dark corridors of site 19 he saw a
different kind of crying it was a woman
with an unfamiliar face probably one of
the rare new refugees balling her eyes
out to a foundation senior researcher
and an accompanying guard with an
assault rifle hot fat tears were rolling
down her dirty cheeks her shaking hands
clasped in prayer she was begging the
researcher and the guard to let her go
outside she said that her son was still
out there hiding away in the back room
of a bank where she used to work they
got separated she needed to go back and
find him sadly the researcher and the
guard told her that this was out of the
question official order stated that
anyone outside the base at this time was
to be considered lost letting her go out
there to find her son would essentially
be condemning her to death no human
could go out there safely but of course
SCP 999 is isn't by any definition a
human when night fell and everyone else
was hunkered down inside 999 found a
small crack in the wall and slithered
out of it it may not have been
communicative in the way most humans
were but 999 was indeed an intelligent
being and knew intuitively that if it
left through a more obvious route its
human caretakers here at the SCP
Foundation might try to stop it and when
it came to saving this little boy 999
refused to let anyone stop it 999
slithered out and through the broken
streets there were no bodies of course
it seemed even the dead could be revived
and assimilated through the power of the
sun talk about a mixed Miracle but the
broken down World outside site 19
undeniably reflected the pandemonium
that took place here 999 would need to
do his best to find the little boy
trapped out here before the sun rose he
lost a few hours even finding his way to
the nearest town where it was safe to
assume that the little boy was trapped
he saw saw those things on the way there
those moving wailing mountains of melted
human flesh each talking and shattering
to themselves in a hundred different
dead voices 999 had been cross tested
with SCP 682 and still those monsters
frightened him he decided it would be
best to stay away from them and make
sure that they never saw him out of here
eventually 999 reached the town
similarly dilapidated and broken down in
the months since the World As We had all
known it disappeared in a ray of
terrible Sunshine more great gibbering
Blobs of Flesh patrolled the streets
looking for converts to integrate into
their biomass 999 could only hope it
wasn't already too late for the little
boy 999 discretly slithered from
building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boy's
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed Foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it paying to listen
eventually it did Slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the boy
inside it could feel the sadness and the
fear radiating off of him as it was the
creature's natural instinct to help the
needy and to use those signals like a
homing beam to find the scared little
boy he'd hid an inside a broom closet
and was quietly weeping into his hands
he hadn't eaten in days days and was
only surviving by drinking the filthy
water from the mop bucket sitting next
to him 999 immediately embraced the boy
covering him in its healing energy until
the tears of the boy's face eventually
DED 999 CED and chirped pleasantly until
the little boy was laughing again but
this momentary Joy was soon interrupted
a great heaving weight dragged itself
down the hall outside both 999 and the
boy could sense its monstrous presence
as it got closer they could hear all
those chattering voices those poisonous
Whispers when it passed the door they
heard it speaking its voice practically
vibrating with the hum of malicious
lunacy turn pretty flowers turn towards
the sun feel it on your face feel
yourself change and SLO and mix into us
become one with our army of One it must
be so lonely to be you Little Flower
walk into the Sun and be us 999 and the
boy remained silent in the broom closet
for hours as the great shape patrolled
the bank outside searching for converts
for victims at times it seemed too
frightening to even breathe fearing that
would be enough to make the monster
detect them it felt like an eternity
until the monster eventually did slope
off and leave them in the comforting
quiet and darkness of the closet it now
they might be free 999 could escort the
boy safely back to the containment site
and into the arms of his terrified
mother but when they opened the door
they saw a terrible sight light in the
distance pouring Through the Windows and
the glass double doors it wouldn't be
safe to go out that way upon seeing this
and putting together what it meant the
boy began to cry he couldn't take
another night in the closet it was all
going to Wither from here until 999 had
a wonderful idea hours later when the
foundation's guards manned the turrets
at the entrance of site 19 waiting for
the inevitable onslaught of the melted
flesh creatures they tensed up seeing a
blobbing gelatinous form slithering
towards them in the distance the guards
who had learned the hard way from too
many lost men that it was better to be
safe than sorry Drew a bead on the
distant shape and prepared to fire when
suddenly their Superior raised a hand
and said wait hold fire is that
999 and it was they all stared in
astonishment as 999 chipper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility watching
in amazement and once it was inside 999
slime parted releasing its contents one
very relieved little boy it seemed
through turning up its it own opacity
999 had given the boy safe Passage
through the Sun and back into the
facility the boy was saved it had won
not long after that there was a tearful
reunion between mother and child and a
brief flash of Hope in this dark and
terrible time 999 didn't stop to bask of
course it returned to its duties keeping
up staff morale and helping the refugees
heal from the horrors they'd seen in its
own little way and for a lot of people
SCP 999 really was saving the world or
what was left of it anyway oh and of
course if SCP 999 had won your hearts
just like it one ours you'd be pleased
to know that you can purchase your own
adorable highquality SCP 999 plushy at
SCP swag.com check the link in the
description to get your own you've been
walking for days your body aches you're
dripping with sweat from The Heat Of The
Sun bearing down overhead and yet you're
wrapped up in layers of on layers of
clothing even your face is covered and
you're wearing thick black goggles so
that not a single centimeter of your
body is exposed your journey has been
long and you feel like you might die
from exhaustion or from overheating due
to these multiple layers of clothes but
dying is better than being exposed you
saw it happen when your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those You Used To Know cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long you might have given up all hope if
it wasn't for the distrust signal coming
from a nearby SCP Foundation containment
facility site 46 any kind of survivors
would be better than nothing no matter
what kind of sorry shape they were in as
long as they were still human you find
your way to an opening in the side of a
mountain and slide into the cave hoping
you weren't spotted the whole world is
crawling with those things now you can't
let yourself be seen as you trudge down
the cave towards the entrance you see
what looks like a huge black snail Trail
splattered on the ground leading into
the facility you try to avoid it and
press on you don't even need a key card
to enter the door has been left a jar
the facility reeks of those things but
you can't see any of them you just hope
they've moved on and left some human
survivors in their wake the place looks
abandoned every step you take Echoes
through the empty Halls when you find
that the elevator's out you take the
stairs all the way down to level B5 ker
containment lucky for you it seems all
the cells are empty now the horrors that
were kept inside of them have all long
since flown the coupe you keep following
that slimy black Trail until you find an
abandoned office there are no people
here anymore just a broken barricade
some empty medicine bottles and a bucket
that the people inside the office had
apparently been using as a toilet you
breathe a sigh of disappointment at
finding no one alive here but you're at
least relieved to be out of the sun you
can finally remove your jacket and head
wrap with your uncovered eyes you notice
that a nearby computer terminal is still
powered up you sit down at the desk and
turn on the monitor because of the
emergency procedures put into place in a
k class scenario like this safeguards no
longer apply you can access all the
information you need up to and including
finding out what actually happened in
the dull glow of a nearby emergency
light you see a dark shape slumping
through the halls in Shadow you tense up
then exhale as it slithers off into an
adjoining Hall you're safe for now the
terminal has finally loaded and
authenticated your access you're staring
at the file for SD loocks proposal for
SCP 001 when day breaks it's the only
name you can give the apocalypse your
world is currently experiencing this is
one of the only anomalies in the entire
history of the SCP Foundation to be
given the apolon containment class
meaning containment is truly impossible
SCP 001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the SCP Foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
SCP 001 and those effects are Beyond
horrifying the SCP Foundation
administrator released an urgent memo
telling Foundation Personnel to make
their way to site 19 at all costs
because they need all the help they can
get those exposed to SCP 001 in the
process are no longer considered human
their new designation is SCP
001a these new entities are to be
avoided at all costs but in case of
emergencies the administrator says it is
permitted to cut off parts of your
transformed comrades and eat them to
avoid starvation no attempt should be
made to kill them since you won't
succeed you'll just put yourself at risk
when the sun changed and became SCP 001
it instantly affected 6.8 billion
innocent people the second the visible
light touched them whether it was from
the Sun itself or even reflected off the
moon their bodies liquefied melting like
candle wax into puddles of living
gelatinous slime this effect isn't
isolated to humans either any biological
entity exposed to sunlight immediately
underwent the same irreversible melting
process into SCP
001 a and the horror had only just begun
people transformed into SCP 001a will
remain shades of their Former
Intelligence and personality they may
even try to will their new gooey Mass
into a shape resembling their original
form form however these individuals will
lose their sense of self if they come
into contact with other instances of SCP
001 d a when they come together 00 1- a
instances will bond on a molecular level
waiting up into horrific giant blobs
with only one purpose integrating more
matter into their bodies that's why they
have to be avoided at all costs you
continue to search the computer terminal
for answers perhaps there was some kind
of contingency plan put in place for
this some way to reverse the effects or
at least escape the nightmare Earth has
become instead you find a series of
attachments linked to the SCP 001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who barricaded themselves
in the facility most prominent among
these were researcher Dr Logan igata her
partner Ari a security officer named
commander anad and a few others Dr igata
had locked herself in the office where
she recorded her final messages to the
world in the first audio log Dr igata
and her companion seemed afraid but
hopeful that there may be some way out
of this situation Dr igata reported that
most of the workers at the facility were
transformed during the initial event
their melted bodies had fused outside
the facility and now they were trying to
bust their way back in the defenses had
held so far though and they seemed
confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape
this awful situation you open the second
attachment an incident report and
realize things may not have been as
hopeful as St igata L on she reported
hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining d-class is
wearing a full protective suit he didn't
last long the huge creature grabbed him
with tentacles made of reconstituted
Flesh it began ripping off his
protective suit as he screamed for Mercy
it was a monster made of dozens of
people and animals he could never
overpower it the second the Sun Touched
his skin he melted away and was absorbed
by the great Mass holding him in place
guns were ineffective against these SCP
001 D super super entities fire would do
no good it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense blobs down and even then not
permanently there was one ray of light
in the darkness the site director had a
secret tunnel underneath his office
connected to a tram that could hopefully
take them directly to site 19 without
risk of SCP 001 exposure it was a good
plan and by far the best option they had
available to them but the best plans
often don't work in practice you open
the next Detachment on the terminal this
time it's a video feed you can actually
see Dr Logan igata and she looks
harrowed by what she's experienced as it
turns out while the others including her
partner Ari attempted to escape through
the tunnel something had happened Dr
igata heard Ari's voice over her radio
but there was something wrong with it it
was too low too guttural and filled with
gurgles
SCP 001 had gotten her she was changed
the monster from above had crawled in
through the ceiling it had taken them
all of them and converted them into
something less than human any hope of
Escape now seemed gone Ari told Dr igata
that it would be fine that it was such a
bright beautiful sunny day outside and
she was wasting it locked up inside that
office she tormented Dr eato with her
shared memories of picnic in the park on
sunny days in the past the monster with
AR's voice did everything it could to
try to convince Dr igata to give up and
join them but she wasn't ready to go
just yet you look away from the screen
when you hear a sound in the corner you
see a dark puddle of some unknown
substance and then some skeletal hands
rising out of it the hands are pulling
themselves out of the puddle followed by
a skeletal face covered in matted hair
you have to stop yourself from screaming
until until a flash from a nearby
security light makes the figure
disappear it's a normal puddle once
again Your Mind is Playing Tricks on you
you open in the next attachment another
video and see that Dr ot's condition has
deteriorated she looked pale frantic and
thin she was using a knife to draw her
own blood onto a piece of Blood Stained
parchment covered in strange symbols it
got a ranted about her Theory what if
001 took the minds and bodies of its
victims but not their souls through
performing some kind of Arcane blood
ritual she hoped to at least rescue and
keep the soul of Ari even if her mind
and body were lost you open the next
attachment it seemed that agata's ritual
worked but not in the way she hoped the
Twisted soul of arri driven mad by SCP
001 had taken over the file it begins
corrupting the text of the SCP 001 file
into crazy ranting about how feudal it
is to fight it then cuts to an even even
more frightening video feed Dr igata in
her sleep tossing and turning in a
makeshift bed in the corner of her
office the camera approaches her in
first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through Dr igot's hair it's that
exact same hand you saw reaching out of
that black puddle earlier you must have
seen AR's lingering spirit with a lump
in your throat you open open the next
attachment and watch the video you see
Dr igata now truly broken she'd been
haunted by AR's demonic spirit for a
long time now and it has clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes
there's only one way to escape but not
like this she doesn't want the gun to
draw attention to her body she doesn't
want to become part of that mass even if
she is dead she opens a drawer on her
desk she's recording at and places the
gun inside Dr igata then apologizes to
her loved ones who are likely long since
dead or assimilated and turns off the
recording for the last time in that
moment you realize there's a single
drawer in the desk in front of you when
you reach forward and open it you see
the same handgun Dr igata was holding is
laying inside you pick it up and study
it weighing your options perhaps there
truly is no other way out then you see
an update on the file one more
attachment has been added while you were
studying the gun you feel your heart
pounding in your chest as you reach
forward and open the attachment the text
has been changed entirely the file on
SCP 001 is now a poem an Ode to the Sun
and to ultimate togetherness then a
video file spontaneously opens itself on
the screen it's a video of you shot from
behind you see those oily skeletal hands
hands reaching for you in the dark just
like they did with Dr igata in that
moment you panic and fire the gun behind
you hoping to scare off the spirit
instead the sound of the gunshots
attracts something far worse the immense
blob of screaming melted flesh charges
towards the office you try to barricade
the door but it is not enough the flesh
seeps and bursts through and grabs you
in its meaty tentacles you scream and
try to escape but it won't save you
nothing will save you the flesh carries
you upstairs out through the empty Halls
out into the cave you can see the light
in the distance as the blob FES you
towards it you won't be alone for much
longer in fact you won't be alone ever
again it isn't easy to work for the SCP
Foundation not only is the job dangerous
you could be eaten by a giant Immortal
lizard or turned into organic Furniture
inside the world's scariest living room
but it's also insanely ly complicated
how do you make sense of the nonsensical
what's the definition of strange when
your career is securing containing and
protecting anomalous objects and
entities rather than a single object
location or being SCP 001 is a cluster
of over 30 different proposals for
potential candidates for the prestigious
001 spot some believe there's a true 001
hidden in this group and the rest are
decoys others think that these are all
just scps cataloged prior to the
introduction of the current
classification system
some even think that all of the
proposals have a valid claim to the SCP
001 Throne we're not here to make a
final judgment instead we're going to
take you on a lightning round crash
course through 31 of the SCP 001
proposals if you'd like a more indepth
take on any of these scps let us know in
the comments but for now there's no more
time to waste after all we got a lot to
cover let's go number 31 the chath of
papers this seemingly innocent stack of
paper is actually one one of the most
mysterious and feared items under the
foundation's lock and key while it
appears to be a simple confidential
report every time the papers are read it
details the appearance of a new SCP that
will inevitably be discovered soon after
the question is whether the sheath of
papers is warning us about these
entities or creating them itself number
30 the Prototype this Account Details
the capture of an incredibly strange
cycloptic creature that emits massive
amounts of radiation and can create
micro singularities the writing of this
creatur file is so basic unformatted and
unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the capture
of this creature that Dr keer was killed
inspiring the creation of the infamous
keer class in his honor number 29 the
gate Guardian this huge multi-wing sword
wielding biblical energy being may have
been the impetus for the founding of the
SCP Foundation this being remains
largely static guarding the intersection
of the tiis and Euphrates rivers its
flaming sword which is believed to be as
hot as the sun can cleave any aggressor
out of existence at the atomic level
when the founder of the SCP Foundation
First encountered the gate Guardian they
heard one word echoing through their
mind prepare and the rest is history
number 28 the lock this Onyx gemstone
and the incredibly complex lock attached
to it are still a mystery to this day
all attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27 the factory as the
name suggests this SCP is literally a
factory founded by a pagan and a devil
worshipper while it's believed that the
factory could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and fear today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses number
26 the spiral path this is a normal
appearing gravel pathway that when
traveled clockwise appears completely
normal however when traveled
counterclockwise the path goes uphill
forever in defiance of of all laws and
physics this simple anomaly opened a
Pandora's box of rampant anomaly
creation leading to a number of the
deadly scps we know today number 25 the
Legacy this SCP is a collection of
seemingly random objects including a
diary from a person claiming to be from
another reality attempting to Halt a
transdimensional corruption that they
themselves created the diary claims to
have a solution to this corruption but
the solution has not yet been found
number 24 the database in one of the
strangest twists on the format this SCP
is actually the various authors of the
SCP Wiki who are somehow leaking top
secret information to the public number
23 the foundation this SCP first
discovered by the FBI is an anomalous
High School building that experiences
shifting internal geometry and sometimes
manifests hostile humanoids within
number 22 36 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability they can dampen or
even neutralize any SCP that they come
into contact with though it's implied
that the 36 may have the power to save
the world every time one of them dies a
supernatural Calamity occurs often
leaving hundreds of Innocents dead
number 21 keer duty this refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
keer class scps whose presence around
each other creates a kind of mutually
assured cancellation if one of these
scps breaches containment that's bad
news but if all of them do it'll produce
a bubble of reality Distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20 oroboros this
is a proposal that's formed of four sub
proposals remember what we said about
complicated these sub proposals include
the children nine anomalous kids who
emit radiation and have destructive
potential in together the broken God aka
mechan the god of metal intelligence and
machines atonement a researcher turned
into a humanoid Singularity with the
power to destroy whole realities and the
way it ends which isn't technically an
CP but the tales of the chaos Insurgency
quest to eliminate all the members of
the foundation's 05 Council number 19 a
record this is an SCP file slot that is
itself an SCP whatever is written into
the slot becomes true and one ambitious
researcher attempted to use this power
to make herself into a kind of all
powerful God number 18 past and future
these scps are collection of powerful
entities that despise humanity and are
apparently the source of all anomalous
phenomena even making already dangerous
scps deadlier than before much like the
database those pesky SCP Wiki writers
might have something to do with this
number 17 the consensus this SCP refers
to a reality restructuring event caused
by an occult war in a previous reality
that's right this SCP already won and
we're living in its new reality the only
people who remember the world as it once
was our 13 people who now form the 05
Council and not all of them are telling
the truth about what they know number
number 16 when day breaks this proposal
details a potentially world-ending SCP
phenomenon wherein the sun becomes
hostile and begins to melt all living
beings into a living wax-like substance
number 15 God's blind spot this is an
anomalous area referred to as facility T
in which nobody can die this anomaly
dates back to the biblical ages of Moses
and is believed to have originated from
the literal blessing of the abrahamic
god it's through a covenant with this
God that the foundation is able to make
limited use of this death free area
number 14 normaly ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the 05
Council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality if
something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business number 13 The
World At Large as the title suggests
this SCP is our home planet earth and
its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on Earth in our reality by
another Dimensions SCP Foundation hoping
to continue human life after some
terrible Calamity in its own Dimension
number 12 dead men this SCP was an
84-year-old man whose body when damaged
and mutilated can affect the very
processes of human Death At Large before
his own death he was used as a dangerous
Pawn in a civil war between 05 command
and the SCP Foundation Ethics Committee
yeah we were surprised to hear they had
an Ethics Committee too number 11 the
world's gone beautiful this SCP
describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the Apocalypse in
which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace before their destruction 24 hours
later number 10 the Scarlet King this is
an extremely powerful extremely
malevolent extremely extradimensional
being its worshippers attempted to
summon him in the ritual that created
SCP 231 and it's believed that he will
finally enter our reality after the
death of scp-231-7 you better hope
you're already dead by then number nine
a simple toy maker AKA Dr Wonder
tainment this is a reality vendor who
appears to be a normal human male but
has the ability to create other
anomalous objects a number of which are
now cataloged SC scps number eight story
of your life this is another anomalous
document that has the ability to warp
reality but only when the writing
contained within conforms to a narrative
structure number seven a good boy this
is another anomalous entity created
accidentally by the foundation itself a
neural work was fed information on other
anomalous entities in order to help the
foundation come up with better
containment and neutralization
procedures problem was the computer got
way way too eager with the
neutralization part number six project
Palisade this is another anomaly created
by the foundation this time to combat a
potentially reality destroying entity
known as the worm the foundation created
a number of alternate realities as
Shields but it's possible that this just
made the worm stronger number five 05
5-3 the final member of the 05 Council
who ironically may not even be anomalous
however seeing as all the other members
of the 05 Council are anomalous 051 13's
lack of anomalous properties is
therefore anomalous like we told you
earlier it's complicated number four
fish hook this is less an actual SCP and
more about the difficult process of
ascertaining the true 001 if such a
thing is possible the very concept of
SCP 00001 is to some degree an anomalous
idea number three the sky above the port
another particularly bizarre SCP
regarding the permanent threat of a ZK
class reality failure how is such a
calamitous event prevented by keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally
entertained the current proposed
solution is keeping the entity
entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation file
entry number two the solution another
one of the most powerful anomalous items
in the foundation's control the solution
is a machine designed with the capabil
ility of fully collapsing reality into
an event of end of world SCP Containment
preach and then finally rebuilding
reality to suit a given narrative
however things took a cosmically
dangerous turn when the machine began to
act on its own when the foundation tried
to reboot the machine it broke and
recreated reality with incomplete data
this is the world we exist in now with
no knowledge of what came before and how
it differed from the world we experience
today finally number one the tendal
Trinity put very simply the tendal Lo
Trinity represents three timelines that
converge and feed back in on themselves
even trying to summarize this one is
near impossible as its strangeness and
complexity resists all reduction you can
hunt down the tendal Trinity yourself
and hope to unpack its Secrets but don't
say we didn't warn you so that's SCP 001
is it one of them all of them or even
none of them perhaps that's a question
best left up to the foundation or maybe
the simple answer is that you're just
not meant to know we're talking about
information so privileged here that it's
protected by a mimic kill agent that'll
quite literally make you drop dead if
you view the files without proper
authorization you do have proper
authorization right the SCP Foundation
is no stranger to Pure Evil whether it's
a reptile that wants to end all life a
sadistic old man with his own tortured
Dimension where the personification of
death itself lurking Beyond a limestone
Cavern but what if there was something
even worse out there the embodiment of
chaos and cruelty existing across
multiple realities and dimensions and
what if it was coming for us this is the
Scarlet King believed by many to be the
ultimate Evil behind much of the trouble
the foundation has faced and some even
speculate that fighting him was the
reason the foundation was created in the
first place but what exactly is the
Scarlet King he's known by many names
names almost always including some
illusion to the color red and then a
reference to royalty or power harak
karak the red sha the Crimson KH pte 616
Mendes exmachina the Lahar Raja and of
course SCP 001 to name a few and like
many of the foundation's mysterious
enemies stories about his true nature
and Origins abound and are often
contradict
according to the official SCP 001 files
of tto's proposal symbology of the
Scarlet King has existed in multiple
cultures throughout history with the
King often depicted the same way as a
huge red demonic figure often wearing a
gold crown or other headdress indicating
royalty he shows up looking similarly
within different cultures mythologies
despite existing at different points in
history or them not having the means to
communicate with one another a number of
entities that the SCP Foundation is
familiar with are believed to be somehow
connected to the Scarlet King including
SCP
2317 a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer who's
expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 Years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as ker but that has
since been downgraded to Safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible d damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
05 Council so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the Scarlet King we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it Dr Robert
Monto if that name feels oddly familiar
to you it's because of its association
with one of the Scarlet King's most
recent attempts to enter our reality SCP
231 this SCP often referred to as the
brides of the Scarlet King was formed of
seven women seven by the way being an
extremely significant number for the
king all kidnapped by the most recent
and a long line of the king's devoted
Colts known as the children of the
Scarlet King each of these seven
unfortunate women were impregnated with
anomalous Horrors such as the Infamous
SCP 682 and every time one of these
Horrors were birthed a catastrophe
occurred and the mother died at the time
Dr Monto was a prominent researcher
studying this anomaly and as six
catastrophes had already occurred
pressure was mounting to figure out a
way to prevent the final birth but as he
was working on the issue Dr Monto was
struck with a personal tragedy the
mysterious disappearance of his
14-year-old brother Jacob in his fear
and anger Monto believed that this must
have something to do with the Scarlet
King and his disciples wanting Revenge
monok proposed an idea so horrifying
that the details were never made public
a procedure known as 110 Monto to be
performed on the final bride at regular
intervals however this wasn't the end of
Dr monto's front relationship with the
Scarlet King it was just the beginning
to give you some perspective on just how
dangerous the Scarlet King is the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition decided to put aside their
differences and form a joint effort to
Stamp Out the children of the Scarlet
King they were successful in this
Mission and even managed to capture the
children's leader a mysterious man named
depesh spivac Dr Monto who became the
lead researcher on 231 and
2317 was naturally the first choice for
interviewing depesh about the true
nature of the children and of the
Scarlet King Dr Monto could never be the
impartial interviewer that the SCP
Foundation wanted though the suspicion
that the Scarlet king or the children
had something to do with the loss of his
younger brother still lingered just
beneath the surface like a lot of cult
leaders depesh was extremely cryptic in
his answers to Dr monto's questioning
he'd already heard of the doctor from
the reputation of the horrifying Monto
procedure and was surprised to see him
so calm and courteous in person a few
key facts about the king and his cult
were revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the Serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical Wanderers
library to assist in their summoning
rituals depes also revealed that the
Scarlet King is bound by Three Laws the
law of blood the law of concrete and the
law of howling Dr Monto confused and
frustrated by dep pes's secrecy had to
learn more he found an old Memoir from a
former member of the children of the
Scarlet King Jack hir who had the
ability to invade the minds of people
from the past and experience what they
experienced he recounted a battle
between the Scarlet King and his
followers and a group of time-traveling
turkman Warriors from SCP
3838 Hurst saw both sides of the battle
from the perspective Ive of the children
of the Scarlet King their lord ruled
over them from an immense Fortress
embedded in a volcano from the
perspective of the Turk men the children
were starved and beaten peasants
commanded by the king's voice and the
Roaring howl of the wind Monto also
found extensive records of summoning
rituals performed by various Scarlet
King aligned Cults interestingly some of
them Incorporated the use of carved SCP
Foundation symbols what could this mean
mon returned again to depesh who finally
gave him the truth about the law of
blood this is the law of the Scarlet
King it's defined by poverty violence
starvation hate and most of all fear
like the Surfs in the Middle Ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the Nobles to the children of the
Scarlet King this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the Modern Age defined by empty
safety and false Comfort buildings easy
to access food healthare knowledge
technology this is everything that the
Scarlet King despises but the mystery
only deepened as Monto found files from
a former Foundation operative by the
name of agent D buis Monto learned that
the Scarlet King didn't seem to appear
until after the foundation was created
and in fact it seemed that the greater
interest the foundation took in The
Scarlet King the more powerful he became
how could this be things were also
getting stranger on a personal level for
Dr Monto depes repeatedly pressed him
about his brother's disappearance and
the mon talk procedure during the
interviews little by little it was
beginning to take its toll the questions
still plagued him what was the law of
howling who or what really is the
Scarlet King how did he come to be
monto's search was causing him to act
more like the children of the Scarlet
King ranting about the horrors of the
modern world how all of us are living a
lie how the only honest way to live is
suffering under the Dominion of the
Scarlet King this philosophy is summed
up in the words of one cultist named
Arya Den cartrite who said we must learn
what it is to die to be enslaved truly
brutally enslaved with no compassion or
comp function from our masters we must
learn what it is to be taken towards a
single purpose to know and truly
understand our lack of agency we must be
beholden to the words of gods in
darkness the tempest toss refuges of a
race of fools we must kill modernity
postmodernity with all its analysis and
sneering observation there is only one
rule the rule of chaos for Humanity for
life for the Scarlet King basically
anytime Humanity tries to exert control
over the world the Scarlet King gets
stronger every time they try to
understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquered and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger monok was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Monto slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realized that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
monto's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depes spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and to pesh demanded a final interview
with Monto with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depes congratulated Monto
for finally understanding what he was
dealing with the Scarlet King depes told
him is an idea a concept he is a being
given power through the conflict between
the old and the new this is the law of
the howling the Scarlet King's endless
rage at the direction the world and
Humanity has taken the king according to
depesh hated the foundation's belief
that science and rationality was the
true path to progress the king saw this
as little more than Petty arrogance the
reason mon Talk's procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet King's Realm that would be all
there is unless our world and especially
the foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Monto his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depes told
him the answer no and in response Monto
shot him dead finally bringing an end to
the children of the Scarlet King in
light of his new Revelations Monto
begged the 05 Council to change their
ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying monto's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat pose by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the 05 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ker to safe and made its description on
the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the 05 Council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow but
Monto knew it wasn't enough he had seen
the truth and he couldn't unsee it while
the foundation was going on as normal
Monto grew to despise them he knew the
Scarlet King was coming he knew that he
couldn't be stopped and that our whole
reality was little more than sitting
ducks Dr Robert mon talk is no no longer
a researcher for the SCP Foundation no
Dr Robert Monto chose a different path
he's now a child of the Scarlet King a
devotee of Madness hate and Chaos you
can't beat the Scarlet king after all
and as the old adage goes if you can't
beat them join them if you've ever read
the book of Genesis which is the part of
the Old Testament that details God
creating the world and Humanity during a
particularly busy week then you might
just be already familiar with SCP 001 or
at least one of the anomalies that's
been proposed for the title of SCP
001 because of course SCP 001 doesn't
refer to a single creature object or
entity but rather a collection of
various anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation anomalies sharing the name as
CP 001 include the infamous Scarlet King
a powerful eldrich being intent on
ending all of creation that is thought
by Foundation researchers to be one of
the most dangerous beings in this and
any other universe but the Scarlet King
isn't the only incredibly powerful being
categorized as SCP 001 in fact there are
plenty of other anomalies with similar
levels of destructive power and one such
being is a creature codenamed the gate
Guardian standing at well over 1,000 ft
tall the gate Guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these SCP 001 has historically been
seen to have any number of wings between
two and 108 sprouting from various
places over its body including its
shoulders ankles wrists and even its
temples this gigantic Guardian also
carries its own weapon referred to as
SCP 00 1-2 this weapon resembles an
enormous knife or sword capable of
emitting plumes of flame according to
tests conducted by the foundation the
temperature of the Flames produced by
SCP 001 rival that of our very own Sun
for reference the sun has a core
temperature of over 27 million de F and
5,778 Kelvin at its surface or almost
10,000 de F you would expect a flaming
sword that burns hotter than the sun to
cause a considerable amount of damage
even if it wasn't in use but the Flames
emitted by the weapon leave no lasting
damage on the surrounding environment it
is capable though of annihilating
anything that Strays too close to SCP
001 burning them so intensely that their
atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate Guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
Gateway which is equally tall as SCP 001
itself behind the guardian is a lush
Grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to SCP
001 this Grove is thought to be the
Garden of Eden the paradise that God
created and that was inhabited by Adam
and Eve the first two humans in
existence according to the Book of
Genesis as the tale goes the pair were
created by God himself and permitted to
live in the Garden of Eden as long as
they followed a single rule Adam and Eve
were instructed not to eat any of the
fruit That Grew From certain trees that
God had specified within view just
behind the gate Guardian are two immense
trees one bearing apples and the other
bearing different fruit of an unknown
type the one that looks like an apple
tree is believed even by some in the
foundation to be the biblical tree of
knowledge that Eve was convinced to pick
a fateful Apple from after an encounter
with a snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
Gateway and verify if the realm Beyond
is truly the Bible's own Garden of Eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of SCP
001 is instantly vaporized the gate
Guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to Smite
any person that gets Too Close The
Guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nond to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at SCP 001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
Guardian will be able to sub atomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to lift a finger
during an experiment involving SCP 001
on December 26th 2004 an SCP Foundation
nuclear submarine called Nautilus
launched a series of multi- Warhead
intercontinental ballistic missiles at
the gate Guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
deaths of approximately 35,000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 Boxing Day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35,000 victims families
friends and other related individuals in
order to avoid questioning the SCP
Foundation administered amnestics on an
almost worldwide scale and the 05 count
Council banned any further tests on SCP
001 that involved nuclear weapons in
what was hoped by the foundation to be a
test with lower Stakes they sent an
Expendable d-class Personnel towards SCP
001 the d-class approached the area
where the gate Guardian is located and
as soon as they saw it they could hear a
very clear command in their mind leave
the d-class Personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or I would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need a thft tall entity with
a flaming sword to tell them twice the
researchers running the experiment were
not swayed by the request and ordered
the d-class to continue moving towards
SCP 001 when the d-class continued to
ignore their commands they were
terminated as his standard policy when
dealing with an insubordinate member of
d-class SCP 001 appeared not to like
this for some reason though and the
researcher site as well as the
researchers themselves were immed
immediately obliterated by an unknown
Force though it's a pretty safe guess
that a certain flaming weapon was
responsible this candidate for SCP 001
may be one of if not the most powerful
being that the SCP Foundation has ever
encountered and according to its entry
in the SCP 001 file the guardian is even
responsible for the creation of the
foundation itself if the file is to be
believed the administrator of the SCP
Foundation one day heard a word echoing
through his head
prepare this one-word instruction led
him to starting the SCP Foundation
containing countless dangerous anomalies
and entities in preparation for an
uncertain future in all that time since
the very beginning of the foundation the
gate Guardian has remained standing at
its post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards Humanity the gate
Guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at Le at least as individuals
it rarely interacts with human beings
when left unprovoked and venturing too
close to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to SCP 001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence
ignore These Warnings though and SCP 001
has no qualms about completely
eliminating you from reality given its
enormous destructive potential it is no
wonder that the foundation has tried to
use the gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous scps each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate Guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
SCP 682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hardto destroy reptile due
to to the malicious contempt SCP 682
holds for human beings and all other
forms of life it is perhaps one of the
most dangerous anomalies the SCP
Foundation has in containment SCP 682 is
also one of the few creatures the
foundation actively wants to terminate a
task made that much harder given that
682 can regenerate its entire form from
as little as a single cell the gate
Guardian had already shown time and time
again that it was capable of massive
destruction and researchers working for
the foundation HED to harness that power
to rid the world of SCP 682 for good 682
was placed on an unmanned vehicle and
carried to within 1 km of the gate
Guardian the guardian attacked the
vehicle seriously wounding but not
killing 682 it seemed even the mighty
SCP 001 couldn't kill the hardto destroy
reptile while the researchers were
disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the Guardian 682
mentioned that the gate Guardian is not
uel but a pretender uel is the Archangel
that some religious text describe as the
guardian standing at the Gate of Eden
with a fiery sword so does this mean
that 682 knows that the gate Guardian is
not actually an angel or that the
location it is guarding isn't the Garden
of Eden at all any truth or meaning
behind these comments has as of yet been
undetermined by the SCP Foundation a
later experiment involved both SCP 001
and SCP 073 the anomaly otherwise known
as Cain Cain is a male humanoid of
possible Arabic descent whose arms legs
spine and shoulders are replaced in an
almost cyborg like fashion with buril
bronze much like the gate Guardian SCP
073 may also be the same as the one
mentioned in the Bible's Book of Genesis
who according to the biblical story
murdered his own brother Abel out of
spite as punishment for his actions Cain
was cursed to eternally suffer for his
wrongdoing in the case of SCP 073 any
damage inflicted on him is deflected
back to the attacker but Cain is made to
feel the pain of the attack any plants
or plant-based matter Withers and rots
in his presence and he is cursed with a
perfect memory keeping him forever
haunted by his murder of AEL when Cain
was brought before the gate Guardian an
unknown incident occurred the
foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
Kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on SCP 001 the encounter left SCP
073 unconscious and even permanently
blinded nearby research Personnel it was
as a direct result of this incident that
the 05 Council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on SCP 001 with the
administrator even filing an executive
order that no scps be exposed to the
guardian and that SCP 001 was to never
be used for the attempted termination of
other
scps of course perhaps it wasn't just
the mistakes of the past that made the
council decide that SCP 001 was best
left alone at some point an artic
transmission was received from site Zero
by Foundation Personnel detailing an XK
Class end of the world scenario in the
transmission the sender believed to be
another member of the SCP Foundation
described an event during which the gate
Guardian finally left its post stepping
away from the entrance to the Garden of
Eden SCP 001 has left its location the
suender wrote the gate is open they are
riding forth oh God it's so beautiful
the transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the Lord shall
reign forever and here o Israel the Lord
Our God the Lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world World some believe that
once God deems it time his Angelic
armies will lay waste to the Earth in
order to remake it as a paradise when
this occurs as CP 001 the gate Guardian
will open the gate he stands in front of
allowing the other beings like it to
emerge into our world ready to cleanse
it perhaps most interesting is the
source of the message the transmission
was received from within the foundation
from site zero however when questioned
by Personnel 054 told them that no such
message had been sent or even existed
while some disregarded the transmission
telling of the end of the world as a
hoax it was then that a time stamp was
discovered this warning had not been
sent from site zero at least not yet and
was dated several years in the future
despite this ominous warning of things
to come the gate Guardian remains
inactive standing at the threshold to
Eden waiting the Scarlet King is a
really bad guy he's a giant
interdimensional nightmare God intent on
breaching our reality and Wrecking
terrible havoc on everything we know and
love he's been responsible for Untold
suffering and Chaos across countless
worlds timelines and layers of reality
to many he's even somewhat of a final
boss to the SCP Foundation and just when
you think he couldn't get any worse it
turns out that he's also a deadbeat dad
not only did the Scarlet King once have
a cult literally named the the children
of the Scarlet King before it was
destroyed by Dr monok and the SCP
Foundation he also had at least seven
actual children each one is speculated
to be a powerful anomaly but it's tough
to find concrete answers as to who or
what exactly most of them are so today
we're putting on our researcher hats and
digging deep into the foundation's lore
to present our theories on the potential
progyny of the SCP foundation's greatest
enemy and if nothing else we may finally
be able to get this dark lord of all
evil to start paying all the child
support he probably owes by now first if
you're not well versed in Scarlet King
Vore you may be wondering how exactly
does an evil chaos God have kids is
there a Scarlet Queen out there who
prefers to stay out of the Limelight the
answer isn't quite that simple and it
has everything to do with SCP 231 and
Big Red's most devoted cult the
non-biological Children of the Scarlet
King they kidnapped a group of seven
girls and performed a number of dark
rituals that resulted in them becoming
vessels for the Scarlet King seven
terrible kids these seven girls have
become known as SCP 231 anyone who
accesses those files and trust us they
aren't a pretty sight we'll find that
the containment procedures mostly
involve performing the infamous monok
procedure on the surviving girls to keep
them from giving birth six of the Seven
Brides have given birth to nightmares
Beyond Comprehension and are now dead
with only one still remaining
successfully contained but here at the
SCP Foundation you need to learn to
comprehend the
incomprehensible according to a
classified document SCP 231 May
technically be a neutralized anomaly
without us even knowing and incidentally
this gives us our most certain answer on
the children of the Scarlet King on this
one the Apple fell very very far from
the tree according to the secret
document SCP 999 that that's right the
adorable Tickle Monster is the seventh
child of the Scarlet King he must be so
disappointed that everyone's favorite
little blob didn't want to join the
family business of absolute evil for
anyone who doesn't know SCP 999 is a
slimy yellow entity that only seems
capable of absolute compassion it brings
joy to everyone in its presence and with
prolonged exposure it can even cure
disorders like PTSD anxiety and
depression he's so good at this that he
even cured SCP
p2317 his deao mother of her trauma and
allowed her to return happily to her
family after some amnestic treatment the
Scarlet King has another good reason to
be ashamed of his cheerful Blobby son
ancient DVID prophecy dictates that SCP
999 May someday become so powerful that
his force of absolute love and good
overwhelms the Scarlet King's evil and
Chaos think of him as the Luke Skywalker
to the Scarlet King's Darth Vader though
we probably can't expect a cool
lightsaber battle between them anytime
soon how disappointing so if SCP 999 is
the quiet sensitive black sheep of the
Scarlet family who's The Golden Child
who makes his evil father proud the real
chip off the old block that would be our
dear reptilian friend SCP 682 the
malicious lizard heavily implied to be a
child of the Scarlet King if you know
literally anything about 682 your
reaction to finding out that he's the
spawn of Cruelty personified is probably
yeah that makes sense just as SCP 999 is
the Scarlet King's innocent optimistic
young child 682 is kind of like his edgy
teenager still in the middle of a
misanthropic phase he shows no sign of
leaving anytime soon the fact that 682
appears to find anything about the world
around him utterly disgusting seems to
be a trade he inherited from his dear
old dad and the fact he seems pretty
much impossible to kill also lends
Credence to the popular Theory he's got
nightmare God blood running through his
veins 682 has also started displaying a
particular hatred for 999 ever since an
incident where 999 tickled them into
submission so family dinners are
probably extra awkward for these two 999
and 682 are the most certain children
but that still leaves us with five more
children to identify it's worth
remembering that the waters are murkier
from here on in but we've searched far
and wide through the foundation archives
to find possible answers if you're
interpretation differs remember that
it's just a theory an SCP explained
Theory thankfully we do have some
assistance here the tale dust and blood
hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
wrath and 999 was the seventh
representing hope according to this Tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result is
skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the king's forces to
Victory according to One Foundation
theorist this child could potentially be
SCP 239 also known as the witch child
this entity is so powerful that as part
of its normal containment procedures
it's eternally kept in a coma why
because this seemingly normal child has
dominion over reality and can change it
to her whims her thoughts are so
powerful that just her brain waves can
damage physical matter and she can make
things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like SCP 682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr clef has campaigned for her
immediate termination just because it's
safer that way this is certainly a
frightening wonderin that the Scarlet
king would be proud to call his daughter
next the second child according to the
prophecy this child represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the Scarlet King
in his Conquest for this we actually
have a pretty unconventional Theory SCP
029 also known as the daughter of
Darkness if the name alone wasn't enough
to suggest that she's got an extremely
Sinister father she also fits the
profile of being very aggressive and
incredibly hard hard to kill but even
more damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing one of her most
dangerous Powers is causing men to fall
into almost trans-like Devotion to her
after spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to murder in her honor
strangling their victims in hopes of
raising Ki the Hindu God of destruction
whom has many similarities to the
Scarlet King she certainly fits the bill
of someone capable of raising armies in
the Dark Lord's name one strike against
our Scarlet King connection theory is
that the file States the daughter of
Darkness was first discovered in India
which wouldn't match up with the other
information we know to be fact however
while this is a long shot given the
sensitive nature of everything involving
the Scarlet King it's extremely possible
that false information was supplied to
bury the connection considering the
coverups and lies involving anomalies
like SCP 1000 this certainly isn't an
unprecedented move on the part of the
foundation next the third shot
this child is associated with all things
desolation implying destruction fire
ashes pestilence and death across the
battlefield when it comes to spreading
destruction and Death on a mass scale
one particular SCP comes to mind sccp
058 the Heart of Darkness this creature
has Scarlet King written all over it
it's evil it's mysterious it's pretty
much impossible to kill and it causes
Mass casualties every time it escapes
its containment chamber it causes fires
whips people to death with its razor
sharp tendrils and sprays highly
corrosive acid from its scorpion like
tail and it's even red given that we
know for a fact this entity suddenly
emerged out of something that's now been
expunged from the records in an
undisclosed site it's extremely possible
that the entity 058 came from was SCP
be proud of given that it's impossible
to reason with and feels solely
motivated by causing destruction misery
and Chaos we can't think of an entity
that better suits the Desolation moniker
than SCP 058 next skipping past SCP 682
at number four the fifth child of the
Scarlet King is associated with the
loose concept of lack the prophecy then
goes into more detail saying that this
child is powerful in the ways of magic
and is able to use their abilities to
cause great destruction here we have
another unconventional proposal what if
child number five wasn't actually a
child but children that's because we
think this description perfectly fits
SCP
1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
bride now hear us out these are actually
some of the most powerful enemies the
foundation has ever attempted to contain
and we we know nothing about their past
before being bound to a few objects by
the Serpent's hand these sadistic
reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the
foundation can take against them is
letting them have free Reign Over the
containment site they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get bored of tormenting the people
inside as we all know the Scarlet King
despises science progress and order so
perhaps a perfect punishment for the
foundation in his many eyes is given
giving them a taste of their own
medicine the sisters though particularly
their ring leader are a perverse shadow
of the foundation's love of the
scientific method they take these
methods and use them for an activity
that the Scarlet King finds much more
enjoyable tormenting and killing people
whenever these crafty triplets set their
mind to it their horrifically powerful
magic is able to cause massive
Devastation just like the prophecy for
the fifth bride's Offspring dictates and
finally the sixth child of the Scarlet
King the concept associated with this
one is hidden meaning it can change its
face and walk unnoticed through creation
it's also said to have the
responsibility of opening the ways
between worlds and allowing the war to
end all wars to first begin there have
been a huge number of guesses for this
spot with some even suggesting SCP 055
the anti- but since we're having fun
here we also want to make an even Wilder
suggest question we posit that the sixth
child of the Scarlet King is Allison
Shia also known as LS and the black
queen the most powerful member of the
Serpent's hand we get it we have a lot
of explaining to do but hear us out
Allison Shia is a member of the
Serpent's hand or technically many
members multiple versions of her exist
across parallel dimensions in the SCP
Multiverse they're mostly all aranged
Daughters of foundation researcher Dr
Charles Kars this arangement leads them
to collaborate in the wanderer's library
the secret base of the Serpent's hand to
conduct raids on the foundation in
Revenge but what if the leader of these
alternate Allison had an ulterior motive
because in the infinite number of
possibilities offered by the Multiverse
this one was not the daughter of Charles
gears but the Scarlet King she's merely
using the pain of her counterparts to
manipulate them into accomplishing her
true father's goal undermining the SCP
Foundation let's break it down the
hidden child is prophesies to walk
unnoticed through creation not only does
Alison Chia appear human the use of SCP
268 a news boy cap that causes the
wearer to become unnoticed allows her to
walk anywhere through creation without
being detected but most importantly of
all the hidden child is said to be the
one who opens the way for the Scarlet
King's entrance into our Dimension and
Allison Chow has access to the
wanderer's library an unfettered access
point be between Dimensions if one of
the infinite Allison was the secret
daughter of the Scarlet king would the
wanderer's library not be a perfect way
for him to leave his own Dimension and
enter ours she could be the final piece
he needs hidden under the nose of the
foundation and the Serpent's hand making
all the secret power plays to allow for
the Scarlet King's eventual bloody
revenge on our world unless of course
SCP 999 the family disappointment stops
him first we realize that some of these
theories may seem surprising but when it
comes to the anomalous especially the
Scarlet King the only thing you can ever
expect is the unexpected do you agree
with our theories if not who do you
think are the children of the Scarlet
King let us know down in the comments
one thing is for certain we hope we
never meet any of the terrible tyrants
nasty children except the Tickle Monster
of course he can hang with us any time
any changes today the younger security
officer Zach asked as he stepped into
the Watchtower as if replied his
Superior a jaded cynical old man who
insisted on being referred to as Mr
Jefferson the darn thing hasn't moved
spoken or done so much as stretch one of
those wings of his another day at the
office then Zach jumed through the
window the pair of them looked through
at the Towering figure a few kilometers
away SCP 001 the gate Guardian stood
motionless its fiery sword in its hand
every protecting its post at the
precipice between our world and Paradise
it had long been stationed at the
entrance of a dimensional Gateway that
led to what was believed to be the
Garden of Eden described in the biblical
Old Testament much like the security
officers in the foundation's base tasked
with watching The Guardian this was
pretty much the extent of the day's
activities hey did you see that news
about the uh transfer posting Zack asked
trying to Stave off boredom with as much
conversation he could squeeze out of his
fellow officer yeah I saw it Mr
Jefferson scoffed rolling his eyes what
possesses someone like Robert Monto to
come down here must have wanted a
quieter post Zach reasoned looking out
at the Stillness of the gate Guardian
won't find one any quieter than here
Jefferson mused him showing up will be
the most exciting thing that's happened
here in a long while unbeknownst to both
Zach and Mr Jefferson Dr Robert Monto
would be only joining the team at the
gate Guardian observation site for short
while not one of them nor anybody else
within the foundation could ever guess
monto's true intentions behind venturing
there in the first place he wanted an
audience with the gate Guardian itself
approaching the Colossal 1000ft tall
being Dr Monto crossed the threshold of
the minimum safe distance from the
guardian given the sheer heat of its
weapon hotter than Earth's sun anything
within a kilometer of SCP 001 was at
risk of being obliterated vaporized into
Adams if they didn't turn back which
through a voice that immediately rang
out in monto's ears the gate Guardian
commanded him to
do its psychic message boomed wait wait
Dr Monto urg holding up his hands in
what would have been a futile defense
against the Guardian Sword I know what
you do when people don't listen to your
commands but please just give me a
minute there was silence SCP 001 didn't
reply there was nobody else close enough
to hear Monto speak to it so he
continued you are impossibly old we know
that much about you and because of that
you must have seen things that we can't
even begin to imagine much less fully
comprehend but I've come a very long way
to request that you impart some
information to me if you can he paused
again as if waiting for a reply that
never came the gate Guardian merely
stood in the same defensive unwavering
stance tell me please how much do you
know about the Scarlet King by this
point in time although the foundation
was yet to realize Dr Robert Monto was
slowly going insane his investigations
into an anomalous entity known as The
Scarlet King were gradually corrupting
him as he tried relentlessly to quantify
exactly what this entity was and how
great of a threat it posed little did
monok realize that in trying so hard to
Define and comprehend the being he was
inadvertently fueling its power the
Scarlet King was an interdimensional War
mongerer an embodiment of hatred and
chaos and Dr Robert Monto was slowly
falling under the king's influence upon
hearing the tiny human figure utter his
question the amens gate Guardian rebed
with another single word psychic command
one it had never been recorded giving
before
witness as if his increasing instability
and and the creeping influence of the
Scarlet King hadn't made monok feel bad
enough he instantly felt sick there was
a searing pain behind his eyes like he
was staring directly at the sun
accompanied by a nausea that made his
head spin it took a moment of enduring
the horrific sensation before he
realized what was happening the guardian
was trying to show him something rather
than give any information on the Scarlet
King verbally SCP 001 was imparting a
psychic Vision on Tom mon a memory of
events long past the answers he sought a
warning or perhaps all three the vision
showed monok a time so long ago that it
couldn't ever be forgotten for there was
barely anyone alive to remember it in
the first place it was eons in the past
long before the comparatively recent
dawn of humanity a time only spoken of
in the dust and blood tablet an artifact
of the dite civilization some of the
earliest worshippers of the the Scarlet
King himself and there marching up to
the entrance of Eden was the Crimson
clad eldrich Abomination and a horde of
Horrors with him according to the story
recorded in the dust and blood tablet
this would have been much earlier in the
life of the Scarlet King perhaps even
before he assumed his now Infamous title
back then he would most likely have been
known as his original name of KRA one of
multiple siblings born when the tree of
life was planted and thus created all
life in the multi
but being the only one of his siblings
cursed with awareness knowing the pain
his existence brought him krock would
eventually set out on his lifelong
mission to destroy all of existence
across every Dimension and he started by
killing his siblings consuming them to
claim their power for himself around
this time in prehistory the being that
would one day become known as Scarlet
King didn't quite possess the power that
he would several Millennia later
although that's not to say he he was an
unformidable force of Destruction fueled
by his singular hatred for existence his
vow to destroy extended to the tree of
life that had caused him to be along
with the tree's Creator and all of their
Creation in other words everything in
the Multiverse all of creation if you
will so what was the Scarlet King doing
there so long ago at the dimensional
doorway protected by the gate Guardian
well beyond the boundary between it and
the rest of the infinite Multiverse lay
the supposed Garden of Eden while it is
unknown if it is in fact the same Eden
referred to in the Book of Genesis is Up
For Debate especially among the
foundation but at a glance even through
the gate it certainly does look like a
paradise the space is filled with Lush
vegetation of astronomical size
populated by a number of beings that
seem to resemble the gate Guardian
itself and there protected by its
watchful caretaker are two trees one is
thought thought to be the tree of
knowledge that Eve was tricked into
eating an apple from during the Book of
Genesis the other however Bears an
unknown type of fruit and is widely
believed to be the tree of life now back
in the Modern Age there's never been a
conclusive link between the Tree of Life
mentioned by the davit in their barbaric
civilizations Legends regarding the
creation of the Scarlet King but the
fact that so long ago he and his most
feared generals were bearing down on the
gate guardian's position defending
Garden where there was known to be a
tree of that description well it all
seems rather conclusive now alongside
Kakak were six of his Seven Daughters
each one of them a fearsome Abomination
much like their destructive father as
they approached not one needed to
exchange any words with their Angelic
protector of Eden the gate Guardian knew
what these monsters were here for they
would stop at nothing to pass through
his gate and uproot the Tree of Life the
progenitor of all all living beings in
all of existence even though it was
early in kck's career as the rampaging
interdimensional warlord he so is he was
as steadfast as ever in his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation
every Dimension every parallel plane of
reality every single pocket of existence
across Infinity they'd all come undone
if he burned the Tree of Life pulled it
out at the roots and splintered it until
nothing remained to the on that future
Scarlet King that the same tree had led
to his own tortured existence it was the
source of his suffering and it had to be
destroyed the only thing standing in his
way was a figure as colossal as karak
himself wielding a flaming sword
leave boomed the psychic voice of the
gate Guardian it was like a doorman
standing before a group of Rowdy
teenagers trying to force their way into
a movie theater except these Rowdy teens
were the Scarlet King his his horrifying
daughters and the forces he had already
amassed since his creation the hordes
stood ready waiting for the commands of
their King who they thought would gladly
lead the charge as they marched on the
Garden of Eden to begin the destruction
of existence but that's not what
happened usually the Scarlet king would
never shy away from a fight preferring
to lead the charge when it came to a
Slaughter instead he commanded his first
daughter AEK to commence the first
attack on the protector who stood in
their path
on her foul father's word AIC took her
horde and charged at the guardian what
she and her forces lacked in numerical
Advantage AIC more than made up for in
her knowledge of War she hungered for it
sought Dominion that was her seal after
all and yet in the face of this
impending Onslaught the gate Guardian
remains still rooted to the same spot it
had as always and would always be
standing a number of aic's minions burst
into flames the very fabric of their
crude form separated on a molecular
level as they were effortlessly rendered
into nothingness still the gate Guardian
hadn't appeared to move an inch had
exerted no energy despite the damage it
had done to AIC and her forces in
defense of Eden as his first daughter
screeched and howled in despair at the
decimation of her horn her children the
Scarlet King decided he needed to better
understand his opponent with a wave of
his clawed Crimson hand the king
commanded his next daughter Alor to send
forth her own Army in a tidal wave of
nightmarish creatures agor sent her
horrific children into battle she
possessed a far greater quantity to do
battle on her father's behalf perhaps
akar even believed that was the scotet
king's plan with a greater number of her
forces over her sisters maybe she would
be able to overwhelm the guardian but
even as her own children began to be
vaporized the closer that they got to
the gate agor had no idea she was little
more than a pawn being sacrificed so
that KRA could learn more about his
imposing Angelic enemy another of the
Scarlet King's Daughters a being known
as anit was the next called up to
contribute to the unfolding battle
although to call it a battle UNS just
how easily the gate Guardian seemed to
be eliminating the oncoming forces
without even moving while an outwardly
frail seeming creature unu's primary
strength over her sisters was a
Proficiency in Magic her inate ability
to warp and reshape reality around her
it was that power that had caused her
father to be wary of her viewing anu's
abilities as a threat to his leadership
and so KRA had her crippled and all her
children leaving them unable to
overthrow him but still loyal to their
King obeying her father's command
perhaps out of the same loyalty or fear
that he would harm her and her children
further if she disobeyed Anu unfurled
her magic she reshaped the world around
them making it so that the passage of
time time moves so much slower and that
was what revealed to the Scarlet King
his enemy's greatest strength in combat
the gate Guardian had so far been able
to obliterate both AIC and now oor's
forces without seeming to move but it
wasn't by standing still it was moving
just much faster than the blink of
scarlet King's multiple eyes now that
an's magic had slowed the passage of
time the gate Guardian could be seen
doing battle as agor atrocities spilled
towards the angel to try and overwhelm
it it effortlessly blocked the oncoming
attacks with its sword everything the
Flaming blade connected with instantly
evaporated bursting into atoms as they
were practically cleaved out of
existence by the gate guardian's Mighty
weapon even with time slowed to a crawl
The Towering winged protector of Eden
only appeared to be moving at an average
speed but when time flowed normally
without un manipulating reality the
guardian was simply too fast to be
observed resisting the the urge to dive
head first into the fight himself the
Scarlet King knew it would likely lead
to his untimely demise he refused to
accept that it could not happen but he
still had yet to amass the strength he
would need as he continued his Ascent so
while time was slowed to a crawl and the
gate Guardian was still engaged in
combat with agoro's forces he turned to
another of his remaining daughters
adista if the Scarlet King and his
forces couldn't get past the guardian
they could still try to get to the Tree
of Life while the protector's focus was
diverted aist Unleashed a wave of
pestilence sickness and disease spewing
from her in a cloud of vapor heading
straight towards the Angelic garden and
Eden's entrance Beyond The Scarlet King
knew this latest attack wouldn't phase
or weaken the gate Guardian he hoped the
foul smog would instead pass through the
Gateway itself into the garden as adad
sent forth her power blood and Ash
soaked the landscape around them all the
plants outside the ENT entrance to Eden
withered and died shriveling and
decomposing as the disgusting fog rolled
towards the gate it washed over the
guardian whose form only seemed to Glow
brighter as he repelled the pestilence
it was as if it didn't even need to
think about it still focused on
finishing off the rest of the oncoming
Army as its glow intensified so did the
fiery sword that the gate Guardian swung
with ease and finesse flames burst from
the blade the encroaching fumes Catching
Fire a along with the air itself it
ignited in a wave of fire a defensive
Inferno that repelled this latest attack
but for a brief few moments while time
stayed slow before anu's hold on reality
inevitably broke the king had sent forth
aif of all his spawn she was the most
reserved keeping mostly to herself never
speaking she and her children could
change their faces and forms shift into
anything or anyone and walk undetected
through the Multiverse and now her
father was employing her incredible
stealth abilities to slip Behind Enemy
Lines while the gate Guardian was
finishing off the remaining Onslaught
from kak's other daughters it was as
atiff Drew near creeping unseen closer
and closer to the entrance keeping the
Scarlet King out of Eden that the
guardian seemed to pause it slowly
ominously turned its huge head tilting
until it was looking directly at atli if
its expression could be seen maybe the
gate Guardian would almost be impressed
that someone was able to sneak past it
after all was a feat that no other being
in creation could ever hope to
accomplish but then again with its
steadfast conviction and dedication to
its protective Duty maybe it would have
looked upon atth with anger with a
cleaving swing of its scorching sword
the gate Guardian unfurled a tidal wave
of fire that engulfed everything around
it not just aif but iik aor and adista
all the king's daughters that had
attacked so far along with every one of
their own children were instantly
obliterated they were all reduced to
empty vacant spaces where they had once
been their atoms separated by the
Searing swing of the guardian's weapon
the devastating Blow by his adversary
did little to deter the Scarlet King
from his mission he was still set on
destroying the tree of life and no loss
was too great in his pursuit of
destroying existence
he barely cared that four of his own
daughters had just been unmade by the
guardian anit was still there Clinging
On to time as if it were a thrashing
animal the Scarlet King could simply
make her restore her Fallen sisters and
their forces he had lost nothing but had
held back for too long and slowly drew
his own weapon out of thin air wielding
a sword that was as blood soaked as the
Guardians was hot the Scarlet King
locked blades with the one being
standing in their way way both the
ancient Angelic Defender and the
attacking eldrich Abomination were
evenly matched every one of their
vicious strikes against the other met
with an equally strong Perry a weapon of
extreme allc consuming heat blocks
swipes from a sharp serrated edge that
matched the Deep Red that would be
forever synonymous with conrock the
force of their two swords clashing and
striking each other was so great that it
rippled out from their one-on-one fight
the landscape around them was flattened
wiped clean of any remaining plant life
that hadn't already been destroyed by
the forces of the King's Daughters
despite having acquired nowhere near the
power he would thousands of years after
this fight the Scarlet King was still a
formidable force in single combat and
yet the gate Guardian seemed incapable
of tiring or weakening still standing
strong against the onslaught even after
wiping multiple armies out with its
flaming sword the guardian was still
able to hold its own against the Scarlet
King who was Furious enraged at being so
close to the tree of life yet unable to
get past his Angelic adversary he needed
to be stronger faster even more ruthless
than the warlord he already was despite
unit slowing down time the king and the
guardian were at a stalemate time that
was it the Scarlet King needed more time
withdrawing from the fight he realized
that this was a battle that could not be
won by sheer Brute Force alone his
mission to destroy all creation to get
to the tree of life would take cunning
deception and more time if he let it the
gate Guardian could easily kill Contra
its flaming weapon could cleave him out
of existence and that would end the
king's torment but it wouldn't be enough
a death would be unsatisfying knowing
that the rest of existence would go on
after he was gone the Scarlet King
couldn't accept that it was wasn't
enough so he did the one thing nobody
would expect of him he made a deal with
the gate Guardian it was an action still
fueled by his infinite hatred for all
existence his yearning for total chaos
the Scarlet King knew that one day an
event would arrive where the guardian
and the other beings like it in the
Garden of Eden would spill forth and
deliver judgment on this world and when
that Rapture happened the tree of life
would be undefended the Scarlet King Ed
with the guardian that he would Retreat
for the time being so he could spend
eon's amassing more and more power then
when the fateful day arrived the gate
Guardian would allow him into Eden to
destroy the Tree of Life while it and
its Brethren were busy conducting the
Rapture halting their fight the Scarlet
King offered a crimson claw to the gate
guardian's burning hand returning to
reality from the intense Vision still
feeling sick at what he had witnessed
Robert Monto looked up at the still
silent form of the gate Guardian did you
do it he yelled desperate to know more
through his obsession with the Scarlet
King did you tell him yes did you make a
deal there was no answer from the
guardian just a single word that echoed
through monto's fractured
mind does the black moon howl no not yet
see the boy he was born in a time before
names there weren't enough humans around
found to need them back then he was one
of a handful occupying a Coastal Village
using a tongue long since dead they eak
out a simple life hunting Gathering
fishing the only thing on most of their
minds was surviving to see the next
sunrise yes a simple life free of
complications until the hermit appeared
the boy would remember this man for
eternity Haggard and thin skin weathered
by time and pain a man that emaciated
walking with a long gnarled cane that
honestly looked healthier than he did
shouldn't be alive even the boy who had
scarcely seen beyond the bounds of his
village knew that the hermit was
unnatural an aberration an anomaly he
walked into the center of the village
sat down on a large Stone and waited
nobody dared ask his business nor what
the hermit waited for for then a few
days later the black moon howled the
boys saw The Village's youngest Hunter
freeze one evening while out on a walk
not simply stand still but freeze then
for an instant he became solid black a
Cole statue and as soon as he' changed
he was gone obliterated not a trace of
him remained such is the power of the
black moon it can make any conscious
being disappear in an Instant Turned
black then wiped from our plane of
existence never to be seen again its
choice of victims seemed at each
instance to be utterly random but it
would come for all who lived eventually
this is known to some as the howling of
the black moon later that same night the
boy found himself talking to the hermit
who asked with small frantic eyes what
he had seen when the boy told him he let
out a deep rattling ey the boy curious
asked him if he knew about the nightmare
he'd just witnessed The Hermit looked up
he'd been the first one in the hermit's
Millennia of pursuit that had ever asked
in that moment he knew that he had found
his successor in the hunt for the death
of Ages The Hermit told the boy it went
by many names the great finale The Pale
King but most common of all was the
black moon The Entity existed beyond the
ve veil of our reality a creature of
pure energy though nobody could really
be sure of its true nature The Hermit
had been tracking it learning about it
and trying to destroy it for thousands
of years and yet it only took him four
pathetic minutes to tell the boy
everything he knew the boy knowing still
that something about the hermit was
unnatural asked how he came to be in
this position The Hermit told the boy he
was the counterbalance a kind of Chosen
One destined to face and perhaps even
defeat the black moon someday the
counterbalance receives a number of
truly extraordinary gifts for inheriting
the responsibility eternal life eternal
youth near physical immortality but they
will be haunted by their purpose doomed
to watch everyone they love die around
them as they continue to hunt their only
true equal and opposite the black moon
itself The Hermit in his own eyes had
failed at his duty he had grown weary
and now he needed to pass the duty of
counterbalance on to another that other
would be the boy he felt a sudden and
profound change along with the knowledge
that nothing would ever be the same
again he was no longer just the boy now
he was the counterbalance he watched The
Hermit give him a slight nod of respect
and then crumble into dust before his
eyes the boy the counterbalance looked
up at the sky and saw the Stars
twinkling so bright and so beautiful
little did he know his battle with the
black moon would Outlast every single
one of them does the black moon howl not
without blood the boy grew into a man as
his village aged and then died around
him decades passed then centuries then
Millennia tens of thousands of years
watching Humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit
of that one elusive foe as science and
diagnostic technology gained ground
absorbing and then evolving beyond all
the old superstitions the counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the
black moon though even then it still
remained essentially a stranger The
Entity was entropic a being of pure
Randomness and Chaos without consistent
form it didn't exist in our universe but
it could exercise its influence here
with so-called obliteration events much
like the horrible fate that befell the
young hunter from the village but that
was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg the counterbalance track and
noted obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning Trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year once a
month a week a day an hour a minute a
second it'd spell the end of all
conscious life a total victory for the
black moon the end of the universe the
death of Ages a complete existential
obliteration he was swept up in a
sobering realization he couldn't win
this fight alone however while his hunt
for the black moon had been largely
fruitless the counterbalance had
discovered many other things along the
way strange creatures objects with
extraordinary powers and events that
couldn't be explained with rational
science perhaps something about these
Oddities these anomalies would hold the
key to defeating his Timeless enemy and
and it hadn't just been these objects
entities and events he'd also discovered
some truly exceptional people on his
travels minds and skills that rivaled
even his own despite his age perhaps
they would be the ones to help him win
with the 133 most brilliant and trusted
people the counterbalance ever met he
decided to form a council and from this
Council they forged and directed an
organization dedicated to understanding
and counteracting the strange in all its
form forms with the secret hope that
their search Into Darkness would yield
the answer to the black Moon's downfall
he called it the SCP Foundation they
would secure the anomalous contain it
and protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title be fitting of his new
role the administrator and even the
black moon itself was given a moniker in
hopes of robbing it of some of its
frightening power SCP
001 does the black moon howl only at the
blind the year was now 1987 the SCP
Foundation had been operating for over a
century and thanks to their secret
possession of anomalous wisdom and
Technology their own advancement was
thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity well there still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some IR in the
fire to combat it their ability to
gather Intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new Global
Information Network their top Minds were
also working on a highly classified
device known as the singular conceptual
bunker which may one day come in handy
for combating the extradimensional
entity directly but the most valuable
piece of information they ever gathered
about the black moon was this it
couldn't howl when it was being watched
the very Act of engaged observation
defanged it the problem is How Can You
observe something that doesn't
technically exist inside your own
reality in order to pull this off the
foundation would need to get extremely
creative thankfully Creative Solutions
to strange problems are the foundation's
specialty Flash Forward to 1993 enter Dr
Moto a brilliant young scientist and
conceptual engineer working for the SCP
Foundation with the administrator's
consultation he started the key project
an arm of the wider project orases the
umbrella Initiative for using modified
anomalous objects in the battle against
the black moon the goal of the key
project was relatively simple if people
couldn't observe the black moon directly
then the foundation could make proxies
of the black moon that could be observed
almost like a kind of voodoo doll these
new anomalies would only need to satisfy
three criteria the inability to operate
when being observed a hostility to
conscious life and the ability to end
conscious life of their own valtion when
not being observed through conceptual
engineering a link theoretically could
be forged between these objects and the
black moon allowing observation of them
to stop the obliteration events however
despite being a good idea in theory Dr
Moto's efforts were marred with errors
and tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted Escape by barging
through site 01 the center for
anti-black Moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
Moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of Moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalagtites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for2 seconds almost
all of Moto's objects were terminated in
the aftermath either being too useless
or too dangerous to keep around the
young scientist felt a deep shame but
forged on he made one truly brilliant
creation that satisfied all the criteria
a sculpture incapable of moving while
being watched but would snap the neck of
the nearest conscious entity if it left
unobserved for even a fraction of a
second its relatively minimal killing
left it easy to contain without causing
Mass deaths and despite all the other
deaths that had sadly occurred during
the key project Dr Moto believed that
the lives saved in the long run by
stopping the black Moon's howls would
justify the sacrifice the problem is the
key project didn't stop anything not
long after this there was the first
recorded double obliteration event in
Rome where where a young tourist couple
had both been obliterated simultaneously
all the deaths in the key project had
been for nothing the black moon was only
getting more powerful the shame and the
guilt was too much for Dr Moto he left a
note in his office Reading we've been
looking at nothing I'm sorry
administrator I failed you sir Moto's
corpse was later found in the sculptures
temporary containment chamber his neck
snapped the key project was in summary
shut down and its one surviving creation
transported to site 19 in late 1993
where it was designated as SCP
173 another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine Millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the calar balance to
the black moon science marched on the
SCP Foundation marched on but all this
progress all this power was nothing
against the incomprehensible influence
of SCP 001 the black moon was howling
more frequently than ever all the way up
to the year
3156 when the foundation launched the
seek project under the support of
project orastes as more and more people
were wiped out in frequent obliteration
events the administrator became
painfully aware that perhaps the answers
to the black moon problem wouldn't be
found on Earth Earth using
state-of-the-art technology With a
Little Help from the anomalous the SCP
Foundation began work on an autonomous
spacefaring vessel that could search the
stars for the key to the black Moon's
destruction it was an on inspiring
creation a huge craft powered by
artificial intelligence with a universal
translator cryogenic units and hundreds
of autonomous drones to perform more
targeted searches seik was waved off
into the unforgiving depths of space the
the administrator could only hope that
it would come back with worthwhile
answers the first of the three notable
planets see arrived on was one
theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snow storms when
se's drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creatures but
no signs of actual life remained records
and statues found across the planet seem
to indicate that the black moon was
responsible for the destruction of the
plan Planet civilization causing so many
obliteration events that the remaining
survivors went mad from the fear and
stress leading to mass death in the
ensuing chaos the next planet was
discovered centuries later in the year
34.99 while this planet could also
theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface a flaming mess however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
Advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior Planet they
had been driven extinct by Black Moon
obliteration events a century before the
seek even arrived unlike the last planet
however it seems that they accepted
their fate and went gently into the
night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored batlike creatures
that operated on pure Instinct and thus
were not considered conscious enough to
be obliterated the final planet was
reached in
3764 and was the most fruitful of the
three discoveries this planet was hyper
Advanced fully urbanized and covered in
sprawling mega cities with records and
Technology over a thousand years ahead
of Earth before the black moon killed
almost all of them there were a species
of humanoid telepathic fungi and had
developed an awareness of the black
Moon's existence that was on par with
that of humanities they even had their
own equivalent of the SCP Foundation
actively working on countermeasures and
most amazingly of all seik found one
surviving member of the species on the
planet cryogenically frozen the craft
was immediately instructed to collect
the Survivor and return home for
interrogation the administrator Was
preparing for what could be the most
important conversation since he met the
hermit all those thousands of years ago
does the black moon howl only when
waning when the surviving creature
codeen Nam Sage was returned to Earth
the administrator was eager to finally
speak with it like the rest of its now
extinct species Sage spoke through
powerful telepathic mind waves which
only the administrator thanks to his
counterbalance abilities was able to
receive at close range without being
harmed incidentally it wasn't long until
the very fact of the administrator's
nature as a counterbalance came up in
the mental conversation Sage could tell
just by being in his presence they
discovered a number of vital truths over
their brief time communicating that
Sage's survival had been pure luck for
starters the black moon is still very
much capable of obliterating conscious
beings in an unconscious State the
administrator also learned that he was
merely the latest in an extremely long
line of counterbalances across time
space and species though everyone but
him had waved this Duty passed it on
Sage had one question to ask the
administrator in turn what is
SCB the singular conceptual bunker being
worked on and perfected for thousands of
years by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual engineers
the administrator replied Victory but it
will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked saged asked him what good
victory would do him then rather than
say it aloud he replied with a thought
Sage paused and said I see how
Blasphemous of you hopefully it works
after this the administrator proceeded
to the singular conceptual bunker and
entered it leaving instru instructions
for the foundation to be run by a newly
formed 05 Council in his indefinite
absence thousands of years later in the
year 51 Sage spoke one more time
repeating the words hopefully hopefully
before turning solid black and
disappearing the black moon had claimed
one more victim but billions more had
gone in the interim the administrator
had no more answers to give at least no
more answers that anyone but him would
understand stand he was inside the
singular conceptual bunker now loaded
into a device known as toome an
experimental Memorial module meant to
pick up and record all the last messages
of every dying civilization Across the
Universe when the time finally came all
he could do was wait and wait was
exactly what we did does the black moon
howl yes yes it does years pass too many
to count it's a time after name now and
toome sits in the very center drinking
in the end of the universe the last of
all the human colonies Across the
Universe were obliterated by the Black
Moon back in the years
7329 so so so long ago but some of the
final messages of fear panic and
distress still echoed around in the
administrator's mind hello is there
anyone here we require assistance
there's it's it's taking people every
day we need help help there's barely
anyone left we need help hello hello
cabal 0943 we have abandoned the false
flesh we have abandoned the false flesh
the shepherd's crook broken Neath my
knee cabal 0943 cabal 0943 forgive us
forgive us we're going to leave this on
it's so dark outside now it's blotted
out the sun it's I have to go now
respond First Convenience emergency
situation developing require additional
resources my fault your fault our fault
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault all fault rip my brain out
now rip my brain out now and a small
child the last on Earth simply asking
hello into an indifferent microphone but
the administrator had to wait as the
singular conceptual bunker became the
solitary conceptual bunker he was the
last conscious being in the universe and
and still he needed to wait as the Stars
went dark outside only when there was
nothing outside but black was it finally
time for the counter balance's long game
to play off there was nothing left of
our universe the only thing here was the
SCB and the black moon itself with
everything else gone the black moon only
had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this this this doesn't make sense
how can the black moon an entity beyond
our Dimension Beyond physical form take
a step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black Moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can I pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black Moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrat Traer
just seemed to be enjoying himself
preparing for a confrontation hundreds
of billions of years in the making the
singular conceptual bunker or perhaps
the singular containment bunker was a
truly ingenious creation a place of pure
ideas where everything inside was on the
same level here there were no Immortals
no Gods just ideas on the same Level
Playing Field and it was time for the
black Moon's idea to come to an end it
was a trap and the entire universe was
the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and unleash both
barrels into the black Moon's chest the
creature took the H and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he could feel
the light fading under the monster's
Relentless assault until he managed to
get his desperate hands on a glass
ashtray he beat the monster over the
head with it until its grip loosened and
he was able to slide out there the
killer of the universe was on the ground
before him he grabbed the monster held
it in place and beat it to death he was
Gravely injured by the battle but the
black moon was no more here in the
singular conceptual bunker he had won
the administrator no longer the
counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the Jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is this place is only
information there's nothing else out
there not even matter the universe
closed its doors a long time ago this
place can go from information back to
matter with just the Press of a
button let's see what happens when we
introduce something to nothing for a
second it looks as though he might fall
but he doesn't instead he slams the
button on the jukebox
and with a reliev laugh says let there
be light and there was light if you're
familiar with the SCP Foundation then
you already know the exact reason why
there are multiple SCP
001's you may even think you know which
of them is the real SCP 001 but for
those of you who are new here or who
just need a little reminder the
designation of SCP 001 doesn't refer to
a single creature
object or entity but rather a collection
of various anomalies that are apparently
kept in containment by the SCP
Foundation at present it is unclear why
there are multiple files collected under
the shared designation of SCP
001 some believe it is because these
anomalies are some of the earliest ever
contained by the foundation this would
mean that they share the designation of
SCP 001 as they were likely encountered
before the SCP Foundation introduced
their current numbering system however
there also exists a theory that this is
nothing more than intentional
misdirection perhaps the multiple SCP
001 files are an attempt by the
foundation to conceal information about
the true SCP
001 after all it wouldn't be the first
time this hypers secretive organization
deceived us anomaly sharing the name SCP
001 include the infamous Scarlet King
the massive gate Guardian and the
world-ending event known as when day
breaks but today we will be using SCP
001 to refer not to an entity or an
event but to a location a location code
named God's blind spot located in an
unassuming corner of the world is a site
that the SCP Foundation constructed and
designated as facility T according to
their archive it's a largely
unremarkable Place situated at a spot on
the sin Peninsula which is a part of
Egypt that forms a bridge between the
continents of Africa and Asia in the
18th century archaeologists Excavating
the area uncovered the remains of a
stone structure believed to be an inn
that dates back to the second millennium
BC however since the construction of
facility T any trace of this structure
has since disappeared so what makes this
unremarkable site so important to the
SCP Foundation why is establish a
facility if there was nothing anomalous
about its nature what distinguishes this
SCP 001 site in the eyes of the
foundation is the area's profound lack
of any ambient AKA radiation but what is
AKA radiation well according to the
foundation's researchers it's a form of
cosmic background radiation one that's
not overtly harmful to human beings if
you grew up in a strict churchgoing
household then it's highly likely you
would have been exposed to a lot of of
this non-electromagnetic radiation and
never even realized it you see the thing
with Thea radiation is that it is
directly correlated with the amount of
religious Faith a person has regardless
of which religion someone follows AA
radiation will form around them it tends
to be harmless to humans however certain
anomalous entities and scps considered
to be demonic in nature can be repelled
and even fought off with high levels of
AA radiation
the presence of other powerful anomalies
those considered more benign or even
holy can also create an increase in this
radiation SCP 001 has earned the
nickname God's blind spot for a number
of reasons one being that it is the only
place on Earth with the natural absence
of this AKA radiation the foundation has
conducted experiments that involved
bringing sources known to emit AA
radiation into the area of SCP 001 but
when they measured no change in
radiation levels was detected meaning
that the space around facility T does
not actively block AA radiation from
entering it but also cannot absorb or
retain this religious radiation it might
be more accurate to say that the
location destroys any trace of residual
AKA without damaging The Source a lack
of faith field radiation is far from the
only anomalous property of SCP 001
though during a number of tests
involving d-class Personnel the
foundation witnessed that while in the
area it also becomes impossible for the
death of any human being to occur a
discovery that obviously needed to be
researched further the first test
involved a healthy human male who was
left in the containment cell on the SCP
001 site and observed he had no supplies
no food no water yet over 12 120 days
this man stayed alive never succumbing
to starvation or dehydration next a
female member of d-class was exposed to
a lethal dose of cide gas within
facility T and suffered none of the
expected effects Foundation researchers
then repeated this cyanide gas test
using 30 common brown rats all of which
were killed proving that it was only
humans that couldn't be killed while
within SCP 001 God's blind spot seems to
also be able to slow or halt the effects
of terminal illnesses as proven when a
declass with stage 4 cancer was brought
into SCP 001 despite her prognosis
stating that she would be dead
imminently the woman survived in the
area for almost 800 days her cancer
symptoms never Advanced and she only
died after finally leaving the area of
SCP
001 there are limitations to this
anomalous effect though one test
involved cremating a healthy male
d-class while he was still alive the
man's body caught fire just as you would
expect it to to and he was burned to
death according to the findings of that
test and similar variations Foundation
researchers have learned that the
life-preserving qualities of SCP 001
don't prevent death by extreme external
damage one of the final test to take
place with an SCP 001 involved a pair of
24-year-old identical d-class twins one
of the twins designated twin a was held
at facility T while the other twin B was
imprisoned in a cell at a different
Foundation site after observing them for
over 26 years twin be aged naturally to
the age of 50 his twin however did not
appear to age at all over the course of
2 and 1/2 decades it was only when moved
to another facility that twin a began to
show signs of aging the aging process
for twin a was rapid too and eventually
he caught up with his brother being a
benign non-threatening anomaly the
foundation has been more than happy to
use God's blind spot to their own
Advantage facility T was specifically
established on this site to house the
headquarters of the 05 Council the
overseers of the entire SCP Foundation
it's hardly surprising that the overseer
Council would want to set up shop here
after all it's the one spot on planet
Earth where no human being can ever die
of natural causes and will not age for
the duration of their stay of course
this locked the 05 Council to one
location but what if they could
replicate the effects of SCP P 001
elsewhere of course this is what the SCP
Foundation attempted following their
Research into God's blind spot the
foundation's own Dr Marvin Scranton
attempted to artificially recreate the
area's anomalous effects somewhere else
his Hope was by generating a vacuum of
AA radiation that a second instance of
SCP 001 would occur at a location of his
choosing or as his assistant berren put
it they plan to build a box and then
push God out of it as it turned out God
had other plans Dr Scranton quickly
realized the hubris of his scheme the AO
radiation in the selected area rapidly
dropped to zero just as planned but then
something unexpected happened Scranton
detected an increase in Humes these are
essentially parts of the fabric of
reality and are what's often disrupted
by reality bending SC scps something had
come into our world thanks to the the 05
council's attempt to recreate SCP 001
something impossible for the foundation
to measure or observe in other words
Scranton had no idea what he Unleashed
or where it went following this incident
the 05 Council realized a worrying
increase in the anomalous incidents they
were encountering whether or not this
came as a direct result of their
meddling with the fabric of the universe
was unclear but it forced the council to
rec considered the focus and direction
of the entire SCP Foundation up until
this point they had been an organization
focused purely on research but now they
had to embrace a new approach to how
they handled anomalies from then on the
foundation's objective became to
actively seek out and contain anomalous
entities creatures objects and locations
like
scp1 rather than just observing these
phenomena for study they would secure
maintain and protect the final portion
of SCP 001's file is a memorandum
detailing an arrangement between the o5
council and an unknown counterparty in
the document someone named Sheldon cat
set out revised terms for the
foundation's continued use of facility T
Sheldon states that he has reached an
understanding with the counterparty and
that the contents of the document are to
serve as a formal agreement a contract
of sorts between the SCP Foundation and
someone else according to this contract
the incident with Scranton put a strain
on the relationship between the
foundation and whoever the counterparty
is and that the 05 Council are seeking
to make amends in order to continue
their new goal of collecting and
containing anomalies so who was this
counterparty that the overseer Council
was so desperate to appease and have on
their side who could possibly be a
higher power than the most powerful
secret organization on Earth well an
actual higher power of course that's
right the 05 Council was making a deal
with God over how they were allowed to
use his blind spot or at least a very
powerful being that considers itself to
be God the rules laid out on their
agreement stated that no person was
permitted to stay at the site of
scp1 for more than 120 years including
members of the 05 Council along with
other members of foundation staff
management researchers security
personnel and test subjects Additionally
the SCP foundation's Ethics Committee
was required to annually report any and
all of the 05 council's decisions to God
for his own part God was restricted from
smiting or exacting his terrible wrath
upon any member of foundation Personnel
that's right a perk of working for the
SCP Foundation is getting around the
clock Divine protection at least from
God himself that's still a lot better
than an employee dental plan this came
with a condition however that anyone
committing a transgression or mortal sin
was given a 90-day written notice and an
opportunity to repent their wrongdoing
in return God demanded that members of
the foundation only worshiped him and no
other Divine entities I the Lord am a
jealous God visiting the iniquity of the
fathers upon the children to the third
and fourth generation of them that hate
me was written in the contract finally
the agreement between the 05 Council and
God was that they would work together
the foundation and the counterparty
would be equal Partners when it came to
the containment of scps and anomalies of
all the strange and unexplained
phenomena that the SCP Foundation
encounters on a regular basis it hardly
comes as much of a surprise that they've
got a direct line to the big guy
upstairs or at least one who purports to
be still the fact that the 05 Council
have a business arrangement with an
ultra powerful deity like being and
express written permission to use his
blind spot where no person can die or
age is hardly a comforting thought at
least the SCP Foundation only ever uses
its power for good right oh boy here we
go again SCP
001 over 30 different bizarre anomalies
claimed this number one spot in the
database and in a sense they're all
right or are they if you're feeling
confused already that's fine we don't
expect that to change because today
we're dealing with one of the most
strange and intricate 001 entries out
there ker Duty just pray you never get
assigned to it you see when you work
around weirdness you sometimes get a
little weird yourself and nobody deals
with more weirdness than employees of
the SCP Foundation they regularly rub
elbows with everything from Godlike
cicas to hyperinfectious Supernatural
viruses and as the famous Tom Jones song
goes It's Not Unusual to suddenly take
on anomalous traits after consistently
working with anomalies for years that's
how the lyrics go right anyway one of
the foundation's most iconic researchers
Dr Jack brigh is technically just an
anomalous necklace himself but outside
of some famous exceptions the SCP
Foundation is in the business of
containing anomalous entities not hiring
them on and giving them a paycheck and
retirement plan that's why if you
suddenly start displaying anomalous
traits while on the foundation payroll
you might receive a company memo
assigning you to the dreaded ker duty
but what is ker Duty and what kind of
anomalous traits can get you assigned to
it let's start with the second question
first the official cutter Duty
guidelines list a surprisingly vast
number of afflictions these include
chronic anomalous illnesses such as
lycanthropy turning into a werewolf
something called Stevenson syndrome and
the incredibly unpleasant sounding
photonic gastric discharge syndrome you
could also be placed on ker Duty because
you're suffering from the manifestation
of spectral phenomena including being
haunted by Spirits whether they're there
to torment you or protect you the sudden
expression of anomalous traits in your
DNA which is unsettlingly vague will
also land you on ker Duty as will The
Awakening of powerful magical or psionic
abilities especially ones which could be
used in a potentially offensive manner
the ker Duty assignment which involves
being relocated and forced to work in a
different highly secretive location that
will be discussed soon is framed as a
punishment for the people involved that
way it discourages Foundation employees
from ever trying to develop anomalous
powers on purpose so what exactly is ker
Duty and where does it happen to
reinforce that punishment element method
the foundation has spread lies among
their own Personnel about where the job
takes place often involving being posted
in some of the least desirable
Foundation areas imaginable these
include Point Nemo the area of the ocean
farthest from any place of land on Earth
pongyang in North Korea Stonehenge
Roswell lunar area 32 and a number of
foundation waste disposal sites however
the reality of where those on ker Duty
end up is even stranger site 100 which
in this particular instance is the true
SCP 001 this Thal class anomaly is
perhaps the most unique of all multi
anomaly Foundation containment sites a
bizarre Labyrinth of non- ukian geometry
that defies true explanation but we'll
do the best we can in a sense site 100
is a facility with a mind of its own
it's a sprawling underground base with a
layout that defies SpaceTime and what's
more it undergoes so-called migration of
events every so often it will begin to
exhibit a sense of dimensional
instability before teleporting to a
different location somewhere on Earth
currently the primary entrance to site
100 known as Alpha entrance is located
in the Southwest United States though
all signs point to another migration
event happening this very year but
knowing where the entrance is will only
get you so far people assigned to cater
Duty are sent from the alpha entrance to
the administration sector to be given
their initial breaching at which point
the true Madness begins let's take a
look at a map of site 100 yikes so there
are 10 major sectors in site 100 that
you should be aware of entrance Alpha
Administration archives technological
containment bio containment Sapient
containment Cognito hazardous mimetic
and semantic or CMS containment esoteric
containment conceptual containment and
the core sector as you can tell they
have almost everything covered here but
just as insane as the anomalies that
site 100 contains and the methods they
use to contain them is how you actually
get around the site site 100 is a
spatial anomaly of truly epic
proportions while the foundation is
aware of the existence of its competent
sectors it's impossible to map out any
meaningful connections between them it
would be pretty much impossible to even
travel from one to another without
passageways known as The Roots however
these aren't just mere portals that you
can hop through through like the ways in
and out of the wanderer's library each
route between the sectors is its own
complex environment with its own sets of
protocols and rituals required to safely
travel through it root Alf the bridge
between the archives and the
inaccessible core of site 100 is a
volcanic Beach blocked off by an
apparently Limitless obsidian wall where
fish made from living rocks swim in the
nearby Waters root Beth connecting the
core and Sapient containment is a huge
and sprawling fun house Hall of Mirrors
anyone who attempts to travel through it
inevitably ends up turned around and
arrives back at their starting point in
Sapient containment rout dth the bridge
that connects conceptual containment and
the core is a massive ocean that has
resisted all attempts by the foundation
to Traverse it rot Val the bridge
between esoteric containment and
conceptual containment is a massive
field filled with unidentified fruit
trees Foundation Expeditions have found
that it too seems impossible to Traverse
one Expedition team was trapped inside
for a whole year until one member of the
team expressed a desire to go home at
that point they were immediately
teleported back to the starting point
rout saade connecting Administration to
the CMS sector is a huge Lush Forest on
top of a floating Mountain the only
animals that seem to populate this
Forest are non-anomalous flamingos next
we have rup the bridge between the
archive and the administration which
appears to be a hallway on the fifth
floor of a tenement building in a City
that the foundation haven't been able to
locate this building is populated by
non-hostile humanoid creatures we'll
approach Foundation staff traversing
rout p and invite them into their
Apartments offering to partake in
recreational activities with them such
as video games board games or watching
movies the foundation discourages its
staff from accepting any of these offers
while on the job and then there's root
Shin which connects the Sapient and
conceptual containment sectors this
route is unique in the sense that it it
acts as a power generator for the rest
of site 100 as it's filled with hundreds
of large perpetual motion machines
producing a constant 8.7 gaw of
electricity these are only some of the
many roots Illustrated on the site 100
diagram as you've probably gathered by
now it's less like a conventional
building and more like a whole crazy
Dimension onto itself why does the
foundation work to maintain such a crazy
place wouldn't it just be easier to keep
it a secret and contain it like any
other anomaly well side 100 wouldn't be
given the SCP 001 designation if it
wasn't incredibly important if site 100
was ever compromised it would lead to an
inevitable K Class end of the world
scenario because the site is
intrinsically tied to the nature and
containment of literally every single
ker class SCP in our universe hence the
nickname ker Duty for those working at
the site in fact an anomaly can't even
be classed as a ker if it isn't given
permission by site 100
the various sectors of site 100 cover
the entire spectrum of anomalies and
each sector is a massive panoptic
structure connected by networks of glass
elevators whenever a new ker class SCP
is discovered its name and a brief
description of its anomalous traits will
inscribe itself on one of the walls in
its corresponding sector ever been
frustrated when the 05 Council refused
to sign off on an upgrade to ker class
for a clearly dangerous SCP that poses
extreme risk of containment breach don't
blame them it's simply that site 100
didn't sanction the change anytime that
site 100 sanctions a new SCP it also
undergo another unique process it
selects an SCP 001 DK instance for the
new ker and creates a connection between
them using access points known as
thresholds think of it as simply opening
a spatially anomalous door between two
scps much like a good boy another SCP
vying for the 001 slot site 100 has has
an intuitive grasp of the Unseen
connections between ker class anomalies
and each SCP 001 DK instance is a
complimentary ker class that will
essentially cancel out the threat of its
other half site 100 is a containment
Matchmaker It's inate ability to use the
anomalous to contain the anomalous is
second to none first it took SCP 3984 an
anomalous phenomenon that seemed to
prevent death from happening to all life
forms in order to mitigate the effects
of of 3984 site 100 opened a threshold
between it and SCP
2935 also known as O Death an alternate
universe hidden Beyond a limestone
Cavern where all lives simultaneously
cease to exist even down to the
bacterial level by opening the threshold
and allowing these two absolute
opposites to mix it seemed to undermine
the effects of both and create a
non-anomalous happy medium life but
mortal Life Next SCP 5000 7 this
terrifying underwater anomaly manifests
as a series of tentacle-like protrusions
that snatch unfortunate creatures that
get too close and assimilate them into
its own Mass site 100 cleverly opened a
threshold to SCP 169 a massive
underwater anthropod known as the
Leviathan SCP 169 was Tangled Up by the
tentacles but it's too big to be fully
consumed or assimilated and the result
is that 57 is trapped in a perpetually
incapacitated State akin to choking
keeping it contained and stopping it
from going after anyone else let's take
a look at two even more hostile and
dangerous ker class anomalies matched up
by site 100 first we've got SCP
5501 an old camera from the 1800s that
comes with 18 photographs these
photographs act as a kind of portal to
an incredibly frightening alternate
reality that creatures regularly crawl
out of attacking and killing anyone
Within Reach site 100 found a perfect
match for this nasty customer SCP
1983 this is a small house that acts as
a portal to a race of tall monsters with
needle-like appendages that leave the
house in search of victims when they
catch these victims they take out their
hearts and bring them back to the nest
site 100 opened a threshold into the SCP
1983 house and placed the 5501
photographs inside as a result the
Hostile creatures from both dimensions
now regulate each other's populations by
killing each other another job well done
for site 100 another ker class dealt
with by SCP 100 is SCP
p122 this is a deadly plot of land in
Poland which decays in corrodes all
matter organic or inorganic placed
within its confines this would be bad
enough but as you'll often find with
anomalous plots of deadly land its area
of influence is growing even knowing
about it can cause it to become more
powerful but site 100 found its perfect
ker class counterpart SCP
1262 this is a massive mass of plant
matter that grows at a truly astonishing
rate expanding by around 7 km an hour
much like absolute death and absolute
Life by putting 1262 into SCP
p122 a healthy medium was found
somewhere in between and finally perhaps
the strangest and most creative match
site 100 has ever pulled off SCP 3852
and SCP
2547 3852 is an anonymous corpse that
manifests in small towns sewing fear and
suspicion eventually a local person is
believed to be responsible for this
murder and is lynched in a rage by the
town's people as a form of vigilante
justice the corpse then moves on to the
next town 2547 if you can believe it is
even weirder it's a pack of dogs led by
an intelligent ENT talking coyote
dressed as a priest site 100 had the
truly Galaxy brain idea to open a
threshold and connect the two as a
result whenever the corpse manifests in
the town the dogs Rampage in and take
over at that point they set up a kind of
ridiculous Kangaroo Court where a jury
made up of people from the town are
forced to find 3852 scapegoat innocent
if they don't the dogs will simply hold
the town's water supply hostage until
3852 is anomalous effects pass such an
obvious idea now why didn't the
foundation think of that cter Duty may
not be the most conventional easy or
attractive work but like everything the
foundation does making sure site 100 can
keep doing its job is a necessary part
of keeping our world safe from anomalous
threats now if you'll excuse us we need
to get going H do you know which is the
right route out of here the desert is
still the night seems endless silent and
at peace until it's pierced by the sound
of gunshots and
screams deep in the Sahara the SCP
Foundation is Waging War against a newly
discovered enemy a squad of foundation
agents is retreating trying to get away
from the ones who massacred their allies
they were attempting to eliminate the
threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality bending entities of the kingdom
of abdon the retreating agents cover one
another as they make their way back to
the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of abidon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their
superiors out of the hundreds of Agents
sent into the Sahara that night only a
handful make it out alive they are
debriefed by their superiors at the
foundation who classified the anomalous
humanoids under the highest of threat
levels the kingdom of abidon is a threat
the kingdom of abdon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the abdon humanoids were
responsible for the deaths of no fewer
than 75 Foundation personnel and had
stolen at least 12 different items from
the foundation the leaders of the SCP
Foundation task researched team Omega 5
with developing a weapon that would be
capable of destroying the kingdom of
abdon once and for all the weapon they
are researching must be capable of long
range destruction because the moment any
foundation agent gets close to the area
they are vaporized by the reality
manipulating powers of its inhabitants
the project is given the name twins of
God and is led by a foundation doctor
known only by the designation
o51 051 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and 051 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of abdon item
01 and so the Omega 5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item o1 entity
and set up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy the anomaly causes the entity it
inhabits to become intensely radioactive
anyone who gets close to it succumbs to
immediate radiation sickness and
eventually death to stop the radiation
problems the omega-5 research group
intensifies the containment procedures
051 receives reports from the high-ups
that the kingdom of abdon has attacked
another Foundation facility in Sudan
longrange defense is needed ASAP the
administrator puts more pressure on
Omega 5 and especially it's leader 051
to solve the problems of item 01 and
develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end working tirelessly to create a safe
and controllable item 001 entity
although there are signs that the weapon
will work it is still unpredictable when
item 001 is initiated the host entity
becomes paralyzed suffers severe
cerebral hren and soon a new host is
needed before testing Can Begin Again
and that's not the only thing that goes
wrong whenever the anomaly is put into a
new host sudden and random destruction
of on-site structures and Personnel take
place 051 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of abidon once and for
all in order to control item o1 051 has
a mind kill switch implanted in its
host's brains 051 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mind kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the Omega
5 team but progress continues to be made
and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item o1 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power
but 051 and the Omega 5 team need more
data and for that they need more bodies
they consult with the director of site
17 and it is concluded that the nearby
town of San Marco would be an
appropriate place to get the additional
test subjects they require on a quiet
Sunday morning Omega 5 along with
support from a squad of armed SCP agents
Storm Into the San Marcos de la vi
sterna Church during the middle of mass
they gather up a number of the younger
congregants and bring them back to the
site where item o1 is housed the
researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though and
Omega 5 would need to get even more if
their research was to continue instead
of going back and forth between the
testing facility and San Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item o1
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing site 01 and Omega 5
rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series
of research tests a few weeks after
occupying the town of San Marco Omega 5
makes its most substantial progress yet
just as they theorized by spreading out
the anomaly of item 01 across a specific
group of hosts they can control its
powers the test may have cost the lives
of almost everyone in the town but the
ends certainly justify the means the
kingdom of abidon poses an existential
threat to the SCP Foundation after all
and thanks to This research they will
soon have a weapon capable of bringing
them Victory the foundation administer
criticize 051 methods but can't argue
with his results unfortunately 051 has a
dark secret a secret that disturbs even
the most hardened and loyal members of
Omega 5 a secret that has to do with the
item o1 hosts the host that Omega 5 has
made its major progress with are not the
ordinary test subjects normally used by
the foundation no the test subjects 051
makes his breakthrough with our children
nine of them to be exact all between 4
and 11 years old despite being told
specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path it lad the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mine that can
process information
and more importantly can unleash the
full potential of the implanted anomaly
creating and controlling a devastating
power but not everyone is thrilled with
what they've achieved members of Omega 5
are haunted by the screams of the
children that they forc to be part of
their weapons development program they
describe their merging with item o1 as
being a process that rips out their
souls and replaces them with something
much more Sinister in fact all of Omega
5 regret what they have been a part
and what they've done all except 051 the
nine children can Channel unprecedented
amounts of energy from an unknown origin
that Omega 5 hypothesizes comes from an
extra dimensional source which is then
used to unbind atoms at the quantum
level when the right activation words
are spoken it appears as though this
tremendous power gives the children the
ability to annihilate anything in the
entire universe it's a gun to end all
guns and only 051 has the key to control
it the nine children work so well with
an item o1 that Omega 5 reclassifies it
to include the nine children themselves
they are not just the entity housing or
controlling item o1 they permanently
become item
o1 once Omega 5 has a better
understanding of item 01 they begin to
run tests to find out the full extent of
its abilities first they test the
distance item o1 can reach the initial
test that Omega 5 carries out is on a
steel rod placed 5 km away 051 orders
the children to destroy the target
moments later the phone next to 051
begins to ring when he picks it up the
Observer tasked with watching the pole
is on the other end he informs 051 that
the steel rod has been completely
vaporized 051 is not satisfied though he
has another pole sent out this time
placed 8,000 km away from the nine
children 051 asked the children to
destroy that rod mod almost immediately
the phone rings again the target has
been vaporized 051 Smiles the next
series of test Omega 5 runs on item 01
are to determine the maximum size of an
object that can be destroyed the test
start out with a steel sphere 3 m in
diameter placed 1,000 km from item 01
051 orders the children to destroy the
object it is instantly vaporized 051 has
seen enough small tests it's time for
something big so he does something that
will later be questioned by everyone at
the SCP Foundation he orders the nine
children to destroy a church of the
broken God worship site in Turkey not
long after the destruction order is
given to item 01 reports begin coming in
the worship site has been obliterated
with no observable damage to the
surrounding area deadly and precise o51
closes his eyes and takes a deep breath
he looks as if he's overcome by an
immense spiritual experience experience
he opens his eyes leans over to the
children and Whispers the name of
someone later that day 051 finds out
that the target he had named has been
vaporized the success of Omega 5 in item
001 is relayed to the administration of
the foundation they are so impressed
that they make plans to use item 001 to
eliminate the abidon threat once and for
all however one of the heads of the
foundation administrator Williams has
major concerns about the way 051 is
running the program the updates that 051
has been sending have become less
scientific and more
philosophical more spiritual
administrator Williams sends a letter to
051 reassuring him that he is doing good
work but once the mission to destroy the
kingdom of abdon is completed 051 will
be promoted to director and reassigned
to the newly constructed site 19 for the
good of the foundation and maybe the
rest of the world he'll be permanent ly
moved away from item
001 0 51's response is short and to the
point I am fine administrator the
project is finished we will complete our
task when you arrive administrator
Williams arrives at site 00 01 a few
days later he is greeted by 051 and the
Omega 5 team Williams can't help but
notice that 051 has a strange look in
his eyes it is the look of a crazy man
who has been lost in his work and who
has has perhaps lost himself Williams
puts the thought away though and walks
with 051 and his accompanying agents to
the viewing area where the powers of
item 001 will be
demonstrated administrator Williams and
the other agents watch from a protected
viewing room as 051 enters the Chamber
of his new super weapon it's time to see
if their weapon that has had so much
time effort sweat tears and especially
blood poured into it will have been
worth it everyone watches as 051 leans
over and says the name of the abdon
Citadel to the nine children all at once
they start to Glow no one observing can
see what has happened in the far off
Kingdom but they know something big has
happened the administrator is thrilled
but notices something 051 hesitated a
moment while leaning over the children
before standing back up did he whisper
something else to them and then
administrator Williams vaporizes pulled
apart at an atomic level before he has
the chance to scream what's going on the
agents standing next to where
administrator Williams previously
existed begin to yell and pull out their
guns they burst through the door of the
observation room and run down the
hallway towards where 051 and the nine
children are located the arm agents rush
into the room but 051 is gone nine
children are still over the next few
weeks 051 is reported to be seen several
times by SCP agents however no one is
able to catch him and it appears as
though other members of the SCP
Foundation have also gone awall as well
perhaps joining him on the run it is
unclear what his plan is but the reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into
the Sahara make it obvious what the
result of his first command to the
children was there isn't a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of abdon but even with this Victory the
highest levels of the SCP Foundation
have an ominous thought lurking in the
back of their minds where did 051 go and
what is he planning to do next following
the Imp proper use of item o01 leading
to the untimely death of a high ranking
Foundation staff member the weapon was
deemed too dangerous and containment
procedures were implemented due to the
high amount of radiation they were found
to emit the nine children were placed
into leadline bags and buried under 50 m
of concrete beneath the Church of St
Marcos de La Via
etera though all the children continued
to be functionally brain dead they still
display Signs of Life despite their
containment and by order of the overseer
your Council have been classified as a
Thal entity the smell of fire and oil
fills the air the sound of gears
grinding can be heard between the
explosions and shrieks of Terror a man
runs out of his house only to have his
leg grabbed by a metal arm and dragged
back through his front door SCP 001
leaves a trail of metal fragments and
mechanical Parts on the ground in the
wake of its destruction iron chains
swing from its form cast iron gears
whirl within it a glowing light throbs
from the center of its body SCP 001 is
consuming everything in its path after
incorporating the truck chassis into its
being SCP 001 rolls in a lumbering
fashion to the next house it rips the
gutters from the side of the building
residents who live in the area flee
their neighborhood all the while hoping
that the mechanical monstrosity skips
over their house so they have something
to return to if they make it out alive a
section of SCP 001's undercarriage drops
away from the main body it rolls down
the street consuming more and more
material the new entity resembles a
human spine and rib cage it topples over
unable to support itself the ri likee
formations extend out to grab anything
and everything within reach the newly
Incorporated material forms what can
only be described as a head light from
within the eye sockets fixate on nearby
civilians the metallic creature picked
up the people and places them inside its
exposed steel rib cage then it turns and
spots a woman helplessly trying to crawl
away the creature reaches out with a
spiked tentacle and wraps it around the
woman's body she is placed inside of the
chest cavity moments later a severed
hand falls out of the entity and onto
the ground the mechanical monster
continues to gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand on its
back it becomes so massive that the
creature Falls over and uses its limbs
to Scurry to a nearby house there is a
sickening crunching sound as the growth
bursts from within emerges three
humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away the second humanoid is a man with
cogs for limbs he examines the
clock-like components that have been
incorporated into his body then stares
blankly into the distance the Third
humanoid lies motionless on the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically the half-human half
machine humanoids turn and run away from
the Mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as SCP 001 the foundation had
been in contact with the Allied ult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in Mexico being
worshiped by a group of people who
identif ified themselves as the Church
of the broken God Intel about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
supernatural abilities it was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worshiped the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
families in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near laaz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all of the anomalies they
recovered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the the US border the train
heads North along rusted rails just
outside laaz they've come across a
broken down train filled with what looks
to be refugees when the foundation unit
goes to investigate they find all of the
refugees repeating the same words over
and over again but they don't understand
the foundation agents look at one
another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are L makina the machine the
commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards laaz disappearing
Over the Horizon as the sun sets the
remaining Foundation agents hear
gunshots in the distance they stay awake
all night remaining Vigilant waiting for
the exploratory Squad but morning comes
without anyone returning 3 days later
the foundation Force still has not seen
anything since the exploratory Squad
left then as the sun sits lazily in the
morning Sky a lone figure is spotted
walking down the tracks towards the
trains one of the agents on watch blows
his whistle and points to the figure a
squad of Agents rushes towards the
shadow of a man their guns are raised
ready for anything the figure drops to
the ground and begins to crawl along the
tracks the agents reach the Fallen man
only to find that he is one of their
squadmates who has been sent up the
tracks to investigate laaz several days
before the agent's name is DeMarco he is
cover in blood his clothes are in
tatters and he has lost a boot DeMarco
lies on his back with Foundation agents
standing around him his eyes are wide
and wild he keeps babbling on about a
world eater how the rest of his Squad
had been mulched and he is the only one
who made it out alive the foundation
agents carry DeMarco back to the
makeshift base they created by the
trains they need to figure out a way to
get the Convoy moving again but whatever
is up ahead has already taken out an
entire Foundation Squad it had to be
something an anous but what could it
possibly be the unit of foundation
agents prepare to move towards laaz they
start loading their rifles and check the
amount of ammunition and explosives
available in case the containment
process gets out of hand just as they
are about to leave the base a convoy
appears on the horizon it is an Allied
occult initiative Force preparing to
attack whatever it is that is
devastating leaz this organization's
mission is to not secure contain or
protect but to destroy the foundation
may be in over their heads on this one
and the Joint Force with the Allied oult
initiative may be the only way to stop
what is now known as SCP 001 the aoi and
Foundation Force gears up for battle
they set out for laa and what they find
causes them to Quake with fear SCP 001
has consumed so much material it is the
size of a mountain it moves like a tidal
wave of mechanical destruction washing
over the buildings and Landscape under
it whatever SCP 001 passes is over is
consumed and added to its massive body
SCP 001 started as a small mechanical
box with cogs but now has morphed into a
gigantic metal death machine the Church
of the broken God has finally met their
maker as the small entity they once
worshiped has now consumed all of its
members their God is an allc consuming
monster the aoi and Foundation forces do
everything they can to stop SCP 001 from
continuing its rain of Destruction they
fire barrage after barrage of bullets
and explosives into the mechanical
anomaly they bring in air support to try
and damage it from the skies but nothing
works the aoi uses an artifact in their
possession to lure SCP 001 to the coast
of the Pacific Ocean where a trap has
been set for the so-called God the
Monstrous mechanical creature moves
slowly towards the water it consumes
abandoned cars buildings and boats as it
approaches the coastline it even shovels
large amounts of Earth into into its
form causing Flames to spurt out from
its inner workings smoke Bellows from
openings between different mechanical
components like a volcano before it is
about to erupt suddenly seemingly from
nowhere a massive cloud with a reddish
tint appears in the sky Air Raid Sirens
can be heard in the distance the
enormous Cloud begins to pulsate streaks
of lightning shoot through the Red Mist
in the sky it now sits directly over SCP
001 from within the cloud part of a ship
can be seen it appears to be slightly
damaged electricity flows over its hole
the vessel in the giant Red Cloud is
classified as SCP
2399 the underside of the vessel begins
to Glow aqua blue a blinding beam of
light is ejected from SCP 2399 which
penetrates straight down and through SCP
001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if SCP
001 is trying to reach up and grab grab
the vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before SCP 001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light SCP 2399 blinks out of
existence the sound of grinding gears
can be heard coming from within
scp1 it begins to shed its outer layers
of metal then the entire structure that
was SCP 001 collapses into the water and
onto the beach giant cogs fall from the
sky parts of vehicles embed themselves
in the sand as the foundation and aoi
agents approach the piles of scrap metal
and mechanical components they see that
some of them are still moving it is as
if an invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast but little do they know this was
only a piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken God the foundation agents
collect as many of the still moving
Parts as they can they find spinning
gears twitching pulleys and firing
Pistons as as the parts are separated
from one another and carried away from
the main wreckage of SCP 001 they slowly
stop moving and become inactive some of
the artifacts were covered were
identified as being connected to the
Church of the broken God these artifacts
are found closer to the middle of what
was once a mountain-sized SCP 001
hundreds of anomalous artifacts are
collected and transported to SCP
Foundation sites collecting the broken
parts of SCP 001 is relatively safe
however some agents get too close to the
larger moving Parts getting caught in
them and losing a body part or two but
most agents proceed with caution and
survive the collection or deal with
their arms and legs still attached to
their bodies dive teams are sent into
the water to recover parts that have
sunk to the Bottom of the Sea one of the
divers is a local from the area he is
hired to bring up the heart of the
machine since he is an experienced diver
used to free diving to Great depths to
collect oysters from the bottom of the
bay the diver enters the water and swims
down into the murky depths he secures
straps around the heart of SCP 001 and
pulls hard on the Rope as an indication
to the surface that it is ready to be
hauled up the Salvage team on the
surface begins to pull there is a second
slight tug on the Rope then it goes
slack the team continues to pull when
they get the heart to the surface they
are horrified at what else comes up with
it tangled in the ropes is the lifeless
body of the diver his head is smashed
between two moving pieces of the heart
it looks as if he shoved his head
between the slabs of metal himself the
Salvage team untangles the Body Rolls it
off the deck and back into the ocean the
mechanical box which was the heart of
SCP 001 is offloaded on the shore but as
the foundation prepares to move it to a
containment facility the weather starts
to deteriorate hurricane force wind
sweeps across the water and batter the
coast the heart is kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship undocks and begins its
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of SCP 001 doesn't make it to
the foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of a heartbeat the man walks towards the
sound something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the wall white sand the
man digs deeper and pulls out the small
box inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing he holds the Box close to
his own heart it seems to speak to him
the man brings the box back to town he
starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area join the new
religion they cast aside their own
beliefs and focus on the powerful entity
contained within the Box God is not dead
at least not yet but the prophecy of the
Church of the broken God say that when
the heart is found the God will
reassemble itself once again then The
Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities until only he remains it's
a quiet evening at Area 11 where the
patrial Fane spatial stabilization array
is housed a skeleton crew is working
overnight to ensure the array is ready
for its big test the following day the
foundation has been working on a
particle accelerator that will contain
anomalies with the ability to manipulate
the nature of SpaceTime the preliminary
tests seemed promising but a few last
minute tweaks to the array are necessary
unfortunately it is on this night in
1982 that marks the beginning of the end
for the SCP Foundation Dr Calvin Desman
is monitoring the array and he notices
as it spools up that there are some
minor power fluctuation in one of the
stabilization arms this problem is not
uncommon due to the vast amounts of
energy being pumped through the array
and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off which slowly causes the
coupling rings to loosen Calvin desmid
decides that remounting the
stabilization Rings will be an easy fix
and it's a necessary one he knows that
if the Rings fail during the actual test
the array could end up shut down for
months there is still plenty of time so
Calvin Desmond grabs his toolbox and
heads down to the array the machine is
still spooling keeping the energy
flowing at a constant low rate there is
no danger at the moment as the inside of
the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer
ring but then something unexpected
happens the system's primary generator
begins to fluctuate uncontrollably a
catastrophic failure is imminent Sirens
begin to sound the facility is evacuated
and the Chamber is sealed deep in the
bowels of the array Calvin desmid cannot
hear the evacuation announcement the
humming of the array Echoes through the
chamber dampening all sound from the
outside world the array begins to come
online while desmid continues to work on
the coupling he has no idea what is
about to happen meanwhile a team of
foundation scientists scrambled to get
the power fluctuations in the main
generator under control as they
frantically work catastrophe strikes
they initiate the power down cycle but
as the generator struggles to keep the
power flow balanced and energy surge
builds up a massive amount of energy is
released all at once causing the main
reaction ctor to explode the entire
structure rocks back and forth and
Desmond is thrown into the side of the
array he too now knows that something is
very wrong and runs for the exit when he
reaches the door he finds that it has
been sealed in a panic Desmond continues
running through the tube to the next
access point this door has been locked
as well he's never been so scared in his
entire life and he shakes uncontrollably
from the adrenaline being dumped into
his muscles The Surge of energy rushes
through the array towards Desmet a
singularity begins to form in the
containment chamber the array is working
just as it should except that there was
never supposed to be a person inside as
the singularity was brought into
existence moments after the singularity
forms the massive pole of its gravity
causes the stabilizer arm that Desmond
had been working on to fail the side of
the array is ripped off and Calvin
Desmond stares into the naked eye of the
singularity everything is silent and
still for a moment then the singularity
collapses in on itself taking the test
chamber and much of the research wing
with it along with Dr Calvin desmi
sparking wires hang from the exposed
walls and ceiling where the singularity
ripped the main structure away water
flows into the deep hole carved out of
the Earth where the array once stood the
scientists from Area 11 look into the
crater left by the collaps singularity
the foundation Administration sends
agents to collect the staff at the site
and document the failings of the project
they conclude that the accident was
caused by human error they ordered the
array to be rebuilt this time using
entirely automated systems to eliminate
the chances of another mishap occurring
several years after the catastrophic
events at Area 11 a new array is
constructed an intelligent system called
netac is put in charge of overseeing its
functions it is a supercomputer that is
programmed to follow commands but can
autonomously make decisions in order to
prevent any failures in the system
experiments begin and again in May of
2006 the new array soon manifests its
first singularity in the containment
chamber at Area 11 and what happens next
will forever change the foundation and
the Multiverse The Singularity is kept
stable in the array it seems as if the
foundation has succeeded in trapping and
containing spatial anomalies but as they
run more Diagnostics on the anomaly
something unexpected happens The
Singularity begins to grow in size the
point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the
boundaries of the array just before
contact the singularity's growth slows
and then stops netac has made the
split-second calculations and
adjustments necessary to contain the
singularity the artificial intelligence
has saved the facility and the lives of
everyone in it now sitting in the array
is a thick rotating cloud of radioactive
gas and dust obscuring the singularity
within as Foundation scientists work
rapidly to fix the array odd events
begin to occur the workers hear noises
that sound like painful wailing over
time the noises evolve into words and
then full sentences they seem to be
originating from The Singularity using
equipment able to penetrate the thick
cloud of radioactive gas the foundation
scientists get a glimpse at the
singularity to their surprise The
Singularity has taken on the shape of a
human the scientists work frantically to
figure out how the singularity could
have formed itself into a human humanoid
shape Dr J Barton Ramsey is the first to
try and make contact with the humanoid
within the singularity he finds that the
entity cannot communicate in the
traditional sense the massive
gravitational pole of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape its void
Instead The Entity manipulates gravity
to vibrate the suspension rings of the
array itself and create sound waves the
being in the singularity Whispers in a
metallic voice created by the vibrating
of the arrays rings and says says yanes
Ramsey Dr Ramsey steps back from the
observation window how do you know my
name he asked the entity the humanoid
within the swirling gas cloud identifies
itself as having the memories of Calvin
desmit it is not desmit per se the being
in the singularity is so much more than
one person but it was somehow created by
the accident that had sucked Calvin
Desmond into the singularity years
before the entity seems to switch
between the mind of desmit and the vast
Infinity of the con OS The desmid Entity
asks for an overseer from the foundation
to be brought in it has a proposal for
the 05 Council when Dr Ramsey asks why
the entity needs to talk to the
overseers it replies that it wants to
offer them a way out the following day
051 enters the facility and heads to the
observation deck he looks through the
reinforced glass at the swirling cloud
of radioactive dust then glances at the
monitor to see the humanoid shape of the
singularity within he presses the
microphone button on the console and
addresses The Entity to whom am I
speaking he asks for Simplicity sake The
Entity tells 0 5-1 to refer to him as
Calvin Desmond 0 5-1 makes notes of the
events unfolding before him and then
asks about the way out that Calvin had
mentioned the air is still for a moment
then Desmond begins to speak through the
vibration of the structure once again he
informs 05- one that what the SCP
Foundation is is doing by securing and
containing anomalous entities around the
world is like putting a small Band-Aid
on a much bigger wound desmit wants to
propose a final solution to all of the
foundation's problems 0 5-1 listens
intently as the entity unravels the
mysteries of where the scps have come
from he explains that the anomalies that
the foundation has worked so hard to
secure contain and protect the human
race from are actually bleeding into
their reality from a vast Multiverse the
the only way to stop the manifestation
of anomalies into this universe is to
destroy all other realities The Entity
that is Calvin Desmond tells 05- one
that he is able to bring about this
destruction if they release him from the
confines of the array 0 5-1 is
transfixed by the swirling gas that is
promising him and everyone else on Earth
salvation he shakes his head in
disbelief could this be true 0 5-1 turns
away from the swirling gas and begins to
walk away from the viewing glass I'll
need to think about what you're saying
the structure begins to shake slightly
the voice of Calvin Desmond reverberates
off of the array a little louder than
before choose quickly overseer although
it won't happen for decades eventually a
catastrophic SCP event will wipe out
life on this planet perhaps not in your
lifetime but it will most certainly
happen within the lifetime of your
children we will we talk again soon the
vibrations slow and then stop completely
there is an eerie Stillness in the
observation room as
05-11 are relocated to other Foundation
sites and given amnestics the 05 Council
meets in a large circular room with wood
paneling and no windows 05- one begins
the meeting by telling the others what
Calvin Desmond had described about the
end of the world he pauses for what
seems like an eternity and tells them of
Desmond's offer that he could prevent
the end of the world but at the cost of
destroying an infinite number of other
realities this would mean that all the
humans and creatures of those realities
would be destroyed as well was murdering
countless other beings worth it to
protect their own reality 0 5-1 begins
to shake he hasn't slept or eaten
anything since his talk with deset he's
being torn apart from the inside 0 5-3
stands up and addresses the Council he
informs everyone in the room that
independent teams have concluded
Research into what the Calvin Desmond
entity has claimed and they found it to
be true the world really would come to
an end furthermore the research teams
determined that the capabilities of
desmit would in fact allow him to
dismantle the other realities 0 5-3
insists that the council must vote to
allow Desmond to destroy the other
realities to ensure that this reality
could be saved they must strike now
before the world is overrun 0 5-1
continues to Shake while 0 5-3 breathes
heavily sweat pouring down his temples
the rest of the council shifts their
gazes from side to side it is time for a
vot there are eight eyes to allow
Desmond to destroy all of realities and
for nay against the plan 0 5-3 stands up
and walks around the room stopping
behind each nay voter and putting a
bullet in their head he stops at the
last 05- 9 who pulls out a gun places it
under her own chin and pulls the trigger
05-13 abstains from the vote and the
measure passes the remaining overseers
will use the Calvin Desmond entity to
save the reality at the expense of all
others and they soon head to Area 11 to
execute their plan
05-14 and 12 enter the observation room
that looks upon the swirling radioactive
gas around Calvin Desmond 0 5-1 orders
netac to begin powering down the array
which will allow the entity to prove he
can do what he has promised they have
pinpointed the reality that SCP 884 came
from and the Shaving mirror itself sits
on a table in another room in the
facility 0 5-3 stands in the room
watching the mirror to see if anything
happens 0 5-1 asks Calvin Desmond to
eliminate the reality that the mirror
had come from the room Shakes as the
entity uses it to acknowledge the
request moments later the phone rings in
the observation room it is 05- 3 he
informs the others that the mirror has
disappeared its reality has been
destroyed and therefore it no longer
exists there is a sigh of relief in the
room as the overseers realize that this
just might work 0 5-1 asks Calvin
Desmond to continue and destroy all the
realities that are bleeding into their
own this time the entire facility begins
to Quake suddenly 0 5-1 jerks backwards
his eyes wide in confusion and horror
his body body seems to be compressing
under an unknown Force 0 5-1 begins to
distort his legs and arms fold into the
core of his body his head snaps down and
all that was 05- one is sucked down into
a single point in space before it
completely disappears Calvin Desmond
then turns his attention to the other
two overseers in the room who both seem
to collapse into black holes of their
own in the center of their bodies net
Zac's warning clackson begins to sound
signaling that the emergency fail safe
has has been activated before Calvin
Desmond is brought under control the
structural support in the entire
facility vibrates with his words they
are in a voice that sounds strangely
similar to 0 51s your children are free
to live lives that do not end in horror
an end to your Perpetual struggle an end
to Darkness the freedom to live in the
light all traces must be removed this
world must be War Mar clean the
foundation does not Escape atonement it
is the only way out it had been a
deception the Calvin Desmond entity had
no intention of stopping anomalies from
infiltrating this world it wanted to
remove all traces of the anomalous from
all universes including this one and
that meant destroying the overseers and
the foundation itself their destruction
would serve as an atonement for the pain
and suffering they had caused in their
quest to secure and contain the
anomalous Calvin had to lie to the
overseers about the real plan since he
knew they'd never sacrific themselves
and the foundation even if it meant an
end to the anomalies plaguing our world
now though with the overseers out of the
way the Calvin Desmond entity is free to
move forward with its plan and Purge all
realities of any trace of the anomalous
but just then net sax fail saves kick in
and the Petra Cal Fane spatial
stabilization array subdues the entity's
abilities desmit is once again contained
05-30 53 asks net saac how long the
containment array can hold Calvin Desmet
the computer's voice fades in and out
but says given current conditions
119 days 6 hours and 47 minutes 0 5-3
sign
he tells net Zac to make a node in the
SCP database that the Calvin desmit
entity will now be known as SCP 001 then
to make dozens of other randomly
generated entries and label them as SCP
001 as well he knows that they will need
to keep the true nature of what this
entity can do a secret 0 5-3 walks out
of the room under his breath he speaks
to himself they'll say that I'll know
the one true God when I see it and to
give that God everything wants because
that's the only thing that matters
tonight it appears God wants to talk to
me Calvin Lucien stands at the end of a
Dusty table in an abandoned warehouse in
the shadows across from him sit several
hidden figures the warehouse is falling
apart but is suitable for the meeting
Calvin has requested with the heads of
the chaos Insurgency he has completed
numerous missions for the organization
and each one has been successful now he
is proposing one final mission Calvin
Lucian takes a tattered Journal out of
his bag and slides it across the table
to the figures sitting in the shadows
it's a journal with details on the
habits of each of the 13 Foundation
overseers he says there is silence from
the other end of the table a hand
reaches out and grabs the journal the
pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
Whispers from across the table as Cal
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers theyve been meddling with
reality if business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from the
Shadows resumes this time with what
seems to be a little more urgency one of
the voices asked the question on
everyone's mind how do you plan to kill
the overseers they have a deal with
death they are Immortal Calvin smiles
and takes out a small vial from his
jacket pocket with this he says there is
a Silence from the Shadows the journal
slides back across the table and comes
to a stop right in front of Calvin a
deep voice from the Shadows says do it
Calvin Lucien gathers his team the code
name given to the group is kill Squad he
informs them that they've been cleared
to take out the overseers it will be the
most dangerous Mission they've ever been
on and even if successful they probably
won't make it out alive but the team is
loyal they set out to conf the 13th
overseer this has to be their first stop
because without eliminating
05-13 nothing else will matter it is
this overseer who has a deal with death
a deal that protects all of the
foundation overseers from dying if that
deal can be broken then Calvin Lucien
and his team will have a shot at
eradicating the other overseers if the
deal with death cannot be broken All Is
Lost the team boards a ship at the tip
of South America and sails towards the
Frozen Waters of Antarctica the kill
Squad is made up of Calvin and three
others they sit in the galley preparing
for the mission ahead Anthony right is a
battle hardened soldier who sits at one
end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the Insurgency because it
was so long ago next to him is Olivia
Torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the Insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid Adam ianov sits staring in
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and Strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black Tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil Iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck in crew with frigid
water Calvin looks at the jagged rocks
along the shore of the tower there is no
way to safely dock there is only one way
onto the island they know what needs to
be done Anthony waits for the next wave
then opens the throttle to fall the ship
is carried towards the island on the
crust of the wave the hole is impaled
and The Rock surrounding the tower
sending everything flying towards the
front of the boat see that wasn't so bad
Calvin says to his team as he bandages a
gash on his hand knowing what lays ah
head Calvin orders his team to wait on
the ship while he makes his own deal
with death he enters the dark structure
and is greeted by a corpse the corpse
speaks to him ejecting dust from its
lungs with every word its breath smells
like decaying flesh death has inhabited
the body of Dr Felix Carter the 13th
overseer Calvin is prepared though
thanks to the notes in the journal he
possesses without hesitating he takes
out a small bottle of liquid from his
pocket and lunges at the corpse he grabs
it by by the neck tilts the head back
and pours liquid down what is left of
the throat to Felix Carter the corpse
reanimates into the living Dr Carter
death has been removed from his body by
liquid from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin had acquired on a previous raid
on a foundation site seeing that Dr
Carter is now alive Calvin takes out his
pistol and shoots the doctor twice
killing him Calvin picks up the body and
throws it into a bottomless pit at the
base of the tower Dr Felix Carter's body
disappears from sight the overseers deal
with death is now broken they are
vulnerable and can be killed at last
Calvin smiles and begins to turn away
from the pit when he comes face to face
with death she stands with her head
cocked to the side looking at Calvin so
it is you who has broken the overseer's
deal with me Calvin Lucien Calvin takes
a step back why didn't she stop him from
killing Felix Carter something festers
at the heart of the council death says
something that will not die I thought
that that perhaps if I had a seat at
their table I could find it make it die
but I couldn't there are things in this
world Beyond even my reach Calvin Lucien
with that parting thought death vanishes
the kill Squad contacts the Insurgency
for an Evac and then makes their way to
Japan where 05-12 also known as the
accountant has been working out of Tokyo
he is so proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for Calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks to the left and spots Adam he has
already predicted this man has hostile
intentions the accountant walks directly
towards Adam and before he can react
throws the kill Squad member to the
ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where Anthony
has the accountant in his sights of his
sniper rifle Anthony fires but misses
due to being blinded by the glare the
accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as Olivia helps
Adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and Corners
the kill Squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot at him but Olivia
tackles Adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where Adam was standing the accountant
camp believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being captured
by the Insurgency team he senses
uncertainty and his as salent actions
and runs away unable to predict exactly
what they're planning to do the
accountant climbs the stairs to a subway
station and Boards the last car of the
train it is empty except for one man
Calvin Lucien the accountant is
dumbfounded how are you here he screams
I should have seen this coming Calvin
stands up he uses his thumb to flip a
coin into the air on the way down he
grabs it and smacks it on the back of
his opposing hand Calvin Smiles the team
has been making their decisions based on
the flip of a coin which introduce
Randomness into their actions that even
this super Advanced mathematician could
not account for tell me where 05-11 is
demands Calvin the accountant pauses
then shakes his head no if he's going to
die either way then why give any
information to the kill Squad Calvin
flips the coin up in the air catches it
and looks at it the coin is face up
Calvin lifts his pistol and shoots the
accountant in the head a few nights
later Olivia stands on a balcony outside
of an Art Exhibit overlooking the city
of Seattle Anthony walks up behind her
and tells her that the foundation is
defeated but Olivia doesn't understand
how we broke the overseer's deal with
death and killed the accountant there's
nothing more to do we can go back to our
normal lives he tells her Olivia is
skeptical though what about the 11th
overseer and his ability to Olivia's
eyes suddenly go wide she pulls out a
knife and stabs it into Anthony's Heart
the world around her begins to distort
and fall apart it was a false reality
created by
05-11 better known as the liar Olivia
wakes up next to Adam in a hotel room
she sits up in a bed and rubs her eyes
what a weird dream she thinks then she
realizes it wasn't a dream she shakes
Adam awake neither of them have any idea
how they ended up here but they know it
must be the doing of the liar they had
planned for this though with Calvin
having created a contingency plan they
pull out a laptop and log in to view the
classified information Calvin left for
them Olivia begins to type but stops
halfway through her password and looks
up from the screen Olivia pulls out the
gun that rests under her pillow and
shoots at him the false reality created
by the liar falls apart around her
Olivia comes out of the previous lie and
is sitting across the table from Calvin
she immediately draws her pistol and
points it at Calvin's head is it really
him or just another one of the Liars
games Calvin tries to talk Olivia down
and she looks around the room for
inconsistent sees that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any Olivia begins to relax she
tells Calvin that the liar is trying to
gets something from her maybe the
journal can tell them what he is looking
for as long as she still has it Olivia
nods her head and holds out her wrist
where a subdermal chip with a copy of
the journal on it has been placed Calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as Calvin morphs
into the liar Olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an IV
sitting across from her is a former
Insurgency agent Named Sam beel he
explains to her that he is the liar he
was forced into becoming a monster by
the foundation they had manipulated him
but now he is tired of running and can't
do it anymore she is free to go Olivia
hesitantly unhooks herself from the IV
she walks out of the hospital room and
proceeds down a fluorescent lit hallway
as she walks away she hears a gunshot
from the hospital room as Olivia's in
the hospital Calvin and Adam walk
through a dense forest they're searching
for o 5-10 the journal indicates that
the 10th overseer's identity within the
foundation is the archist in the middle
of the clearing are two saplings
standing side by side the void between
the sapling shimmers Calen walks through
the portal and the space begins to warp
and twist around him his vision finally
comes back into focus and Calvin finds
himself in another world Adam enters the
World Behind Calvin practically knocking
him over as he enters through the portal
this is The Wanderer
library but it doesn't look anything
like they expected instead of rows of
books the library is filled with
computer mainframes humming with the
collected knowledge of how to contain
anomalies a critical backup as the two
look intently at the strange machines a
figure in a silver robe suddenly steps
out of the darkness it's tall and thin
and though its hood is pulled down so
they can't see its face they can see
that its hands are covered in scales
that have a slight Emerald tint it is
one of the Librarians Calvin tells the
librarian that they're seeking the
archist but the librarian tells them
that the archist is no longer in the
library she has broken her pack with the
serpent and eaten fruit from The
Forbidden trees if they want to see her
though the librarian can take them to
her Calvin and Adam follow the librarian
down along staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
Scrolls works of art and in entire
universe of knowledge eventually they
reach the bottom of the stairs where
there stands a giant set of brass doors
Beyond the Door the librarian explains
is the source of all knowledge before
Calvin and Adam pass through the doors
though Calvin turns to the librarian
before we go in I'd like to make a
withdrawal he says the librarian nods
and pulls out a silver tube out of its
robe it hands the tube to Adam and he
looks it over in his hands he looks up
to ask what this is but the librarian
has vanished the door then opens and the
two step through Calvin and Adam feel as
if they walk through the same kind of
portal that brought them to the library
and find that they have walked into a
lush Green Valley with two trees sitting
underneath one of them is a woman in a
white dress she is reading a book and
eating a piece of fruit are you the
archist Calvin asks the woman nods yes
and that's all the confirmation Calvin
needs he raises his pistol and fires but
the bullet passes right through the
archist as if she wasn't there do you
read the archivist asked Calvin
seemingly not phased by his attempts to
shoot her I haven't had much time
recently Calvin replied the archivist
explains that she's read every book in
the library the collected knowledge of
the universe is in the books even one on
how to allow bullets to pass through
your body she came here to find the
secret to immortality
it's her job to document everything that
happens in the world and she can't do
that if she's dead she explains that she
figured out that the fruit that the
serpent forbade everyone to eat wasn't
actual fruit but the knowledge contained
in the library by having read every book
she has consumed the fruit she no longer
needs the serpent because she was the
serpent the archist falls to the ground
and begins to ride around contorting her
body as it starts to change she begins
to elongate as her limbs seemingly
disappear the next thing Calvin and Adam
know they're face to face with a giant
snake Calvin Dodges as the serpent
lunges at him and Adam stands in the
doorway firing at the snake with his
pistol but just like with the archist
human form the bullets have no effect
the serpent coils around Calvin and
begins to choke the life from him as
Adam can only watch helpless Calvin
cries out with his last breath the tube
Adam open the tube tube Adam takes the
tube that was given to him by the
librarian and opens the cap a long heavy
spear slides out that looks much too
large to have ever fit inside he drops
the tube to the ground and watches an
amazement as it starts to transform
turning into what looks like a large
Harpoon Gun Adam knows what to do and
places the giant spear into the gun and
points it at the serpent you can't kill
me the giant snake says I've eaten from
the Tree of Life at pulls the trigger
and the huge spear flies through the air
striking the serpent in the head Adam
runs to Calvin and helps him to his feet
they turn to look at the snake but
instead of the menacing creature it's
the archist once again pinned against
the tree she once set under the spear
sticking out of her skull as the two
stand looking at the archivist a tall
hooded humanoid figure steps out from
behind the tree it looks similar to The
Librarian except its robe is a greenish
color color and it wears long black
gloves the creature pulls the spear out
of the archist whose body slumps to the
ground and hands the spear to Calvin who
are you Calvin asks but his question is
ignored after a moment the figure
finally speaks that spear you now hold
is called the Spear of the nonbeliever
it is an ancient weapon used to kill
Gods it is odd that someone in this
realm gave you the spear even with it
I'm not sure you will be able to
complete your quest Calvin Lucien but we
shall see there is a sudden flash of
light and Calvin and Adam find
themselves transported back to the
forest they had entered the wanderer's
library from a week later Calvin and
Anthony Tracked Down 0 5-9 who in the
council is known as The Outsider she
isn't hard to find and it seems as if
she actually wanted to be found they
find her sitting outside of her burnt
down family home the journal had listed
this as her address but Calvin doubted
that she would be here and most he hoped
to find a clue to her whereabouts but
here she was sitting in the ashes of her
home without turning around the outsider
began speaking the council just used me
you know she says they took away my
academic career my friends and my life
they made me conduct research for them
that compromised everything I stood for
and now here I am with nothing The
Outsider lets out a sigh she asked
Calvin if he's afraid of death Calvin
shakes his head and responds no The
Outsider slumps forward and Vin walks
around to face her she is covered in
blood her eyes move to look up at Calvin
you're lying she says as she dies from
self-inflicted wounds Calvin and Anthony
cross 05- 9 off the list and head back
to the car as they walk Anthony says
what's been on everyone's mind the last
few days the easy part is done we'll
only get harder from here we know 0 5-8
is in his castle and I'm sure we'll get
in but I'm not sure if we'll make it out
alive I know replies Calvin but if we're
going to save the world world we must
eliminate the rest of the overseers even
if it means sacrificing our own lives
they get in the car and drive off into
the blood red sunset to pick up the rest
of the kill squad team before their next
mission Calvin Lucian leads the kill
squad team through the mud and freezing
rain in front of them looms The Fortress
of Baron Leman hoodley the eighth
overseer the team has already been
through a lot from breaking the overseer
council's deal with death by eliminating
05-13 to using the spear of the
non-believer to kill the Godlike archist
05-10 the hunting of overseers has taken
a toll on the kill Squad 05-12 almost
killed Adam and Olivia was stuck in what
seemed like an endless mind game with
05-11 the first five overseers were
eliminated but the words that the ninth
overseer spoke to Calvin Lucien before
she died still run through his mind are
you afraid of death now the kill Squad
is about to infiltrate one of the most
heavily guarded facilities in the world
to eliminate the eth overseer upon
reaching the castle the team is
surprised to find the structure is in
ruin no one is supposed to know the
location of 0 5-8 though the Fortress
was supposed to be practically
impregnable they stormed the castle of
058 all the same the journal Calvin
possesses that contains information
about the members of the SCP
foundation's powerful 05 Council
identifies him as a former industrialist
named Baron Leman hodle with with his
vast wealth hle funded the foundation at
the start and was considered the
unofficial leader of the council in its
early days with immense control over the
actions of the organization the kill
Squad makes their way through the dimly
lit hallways of the castle as they turn
the corner they're surprised to find the
charred remains of Baron Leman hole's
bodyguards it seems that someone or
something has gotten to hly before they
could the team makes their way to the
main chamber and breaches the door
laying by a still lit fireplace is 0 5-8
the kill Squad scans the room to make
sure the killer isn't still in there
with them Adam walks over to the body
and examines it he quickly realizes that
hoodley hasn't been murdered at all he
sees that Baron hoddle's body has been
drastically modified using anomalous
technology the overseer used his
immortality to modify almost every part
of his body to make himself stronger
unfortunately for Baron hoodley when the
overseer's deal with death was broken by
Calvin the modification to his body
slowly tore him apart his regular body
could no longer support all the
modifications and what once made him
practically Invincible became the very
thing that destroyed him the team leaves
the castle and Crosses 0 5-8 off their
list on their way out Adam pulls Calvin
aside he has the feeling that Anthony
hasn't been completely honest with the
rest of the team he had the feeling that
Anthony was hiding something from them
Calvin had similar thoughts recently he
pushes Anthony for more information
about his past and Anthony reveals that
he's over 100 years old the vial of
water from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin has was not the only one early in
his career with the Insurgency he had
confiscated other vials from a
foundation site his Squad drank the
water and it extended their lives he
asks Calvin on what he plans on doing
with his water from the fountain I'm
going to destroy it Calvin tells him
Anthony agrees with this plan once you
drink from the Fountain of Youth you May
extend your life but a part of you dies
at the same time vibrancy of the senses
disappears leading to a seemingly
shallow life if Anthony could go back
and do it again he never would have
drank the water Calvin receives Intel
from the Insurgency that the seventh
overseers in a small town in Cambodia
the kill Squad makes their way to the
village and surveys the area hoping to
get a glimpse at the overseer who
codenamed green as the team conducts
reconnaissance Anthony tells them that
that he thinks the mission is a setup it
is too remote and there are so many
unknown variables but Calvin is
convinced that this might be their only
chance to kill green since green arrived
in the area there has been non-stop
chaos she has destabilized the local
governments and now the area is in an
allout War the team weaves through
narrow passageways between houses and
buildings trying to make their way to
the central compound where green is
located suddenly a mob starts to form
they are getting closer and closer to
the team in a quick decision to avoid
being seen Calvin orders everyone into a
nearby building before Anthony can
follow the mob rounds the corner they
spot Anthony and he's forced to flee
Calvin Olivia and Adam watch as the mob
chases after Anthony but they have to
keep moving Calvin knows that Anthony
can take care of himself and they are
too close to their goal to stop now
Calvin slowly opens the front door of
the house they are hiding in and peers
out the coast looks clear so so he
signals Olivia and Adam to follow him
before they can step out into the street
a gas canister enters through a cracked
doorway the room fills with sleeping gas
and the team passes out when they are
awake they are tied up in a large room
with marble vaated ceilings o 5-7 is
standing in front of Calvin she smiles
wickedly while holding a knife she
compliments Calvin on what he and his
team have been able to do so far no one
believed they could pull off even a
fraction of what they have but now she
has an offer for Calvin she points
towards Adam and Olivia and tells Calvin
he must choose one of them to die if he
doesn't she'll kill the leader of the
riers and plunge another part of the
country into chaos screw you is Calvin's
response very well utters green have it
your way she assassinates the leader
being held in her compound then turns
back to Calvin she now threatens to
torture his team until Calvin makes a
choice of who to kill green slashes
Adam's cheek with her not knife as
Calvin screams for green to leave his
team alone and torture him instead green
Just Smiles I'm going to enjoy killing
your friends while you watch as you have
killed so many of my overseers on the
council she reaches up in the air with
the knife above Adam's head before she
can plunge the knife through his skull a
bullet passes through her hand causing
her to drop the knife Anthony kneels on
a rooftop across the courtyard smoking
sniper rifles still pointed at Green who
runs uses the drop knife to cut his
ropes and chases after green he follows
her to the roof where he watches as she
boards a helicopter the aircraft lifts
off as Anthony Fires at it from his
original position but does no serious
damage in the plaza below the mob that
has separated the team earlier becomes
restless there is complete chaos and
someone fires a rocket at the fleeing
helicopter the rocket hits the tail of
the aircraft sending it crashing into
the plaza full of riers below as the
crowd flees from the sea Calvin makes
his way towards the wreckage and reaches
it at the same time Anthony does Calvin
looks at him smiles and thanks him for
saving his life Anthony smiles back but
before he can say anything a gunshot
rings out and a bullet rips through his
neck Calvin turns to see where it came
from and is horrified to see the burning
body of 05- 7 her skin has been charred
black but in her burnt hand she holds a
gun what's left of her lips curl back in
a Sinister grin as she fires a again and
hits Anthony in the chest he falls to
the ground Kelvin runs to him and pulls
out his gun to shoot 0 5-7 but she is
already dead Calvin holds his dying
teammate as blood pours out of his neck
and chest but Calvin can stop this he
pulls out the vial of water from the
fountain no wies Anthony I have lived
long enough thank you my friend I will
see you in whatever lies Beyond this
life Anthony's chest Rises then Falls it
does not rise again again olivan Adam
Round the Corner to see Calvin holding
the lifeless body of their teammate
tears flowing from his eyes the team
holds a small ceremony and burial for
Anthony but are only halfway through
their mission and can't stop now they
fly back to the United States where an
undercover Insurgency agent named
Kowalski informs them that 0 5-6 is
already aware they're after him this
overseer is code named the American
because he has the power of the entire
US military at his fingertips
the kill Squad Scouts the base where the
American is located Kowalski warns them
of a crate that was recently brought to
the base from site 19 the Americans
showed great interest in whatever was in
the container the group sets up a camp
on a hill overlooking the base as the
sun slowly Rises the next day the kill
Squad is spotted by a drone and forced
to hop in their Jeep and try to run they
make their way down the hill finding
themselves in the valley below with no
clear exit in front of them lands a
helicopter as Humvees Roar into the
canyon behind them the team is
surrounded a Jeep pulls up and 0 5-6
steps out he introduces himself as Rufus
King member of the overseer Council but
an American citizen first and foremost
all he really wants is to protect the
country he loves thanks to you I've lost
my immortality and can no longer
effectively protect the United States
anymore the American says to Calvin but
I'm willing to make a deal your freedom
for the spear of the non-believer rumor
has it that you have the spear in your
possession and you used it to kill the
archist you give me the spear I will let
you go no replies Calvin I will never
give an overseer the means to cause more
destruction the spear stays with us very
well the American says with a frown then
I suppose my only other option is to
take it from you but not without giving
you a fair chance run Calvin Lucien run
as fast as you can I will be coming for
you the American turns and walks towards
the container from site 19 which is
being lowered from a helicopter hovering
above them Calvin Sprints back to the
jeep with the other members of his team
as they drive away they hear a horrible
guttural Screech from whatever was
inside the container after a few moments
the Army begins to pursue them out in
front of the military force is 05 5-6
writing SCP 682 he is using a black whip
to urge the creature forward and they're
gaining on the kill Squad fast a row of
vehicles pulls up beside the American
and SCP 682 then something strange
happens a man appears in front of the
oncoming forces led by the American the
man's skin bulges and seems to be moving
from within the skin of the man slous
from his body the infection that is SCP
610 erupts out of him and onto the
soldiers in the nearby Jeep SCP 610
begins to infect and consume everyone
around it suddenly there are thousands
of instances of SCP 610 coming from the
mountain side flooding into the valley
they close in and around the Army and 0
5-6 the American begins fighting off the
flesh eating creatures from the back of
SCP 682 but he becomes overwhelmed he
can no longer focus on pursuing Calvin
and his team from the back back of the
Jeep Olivia pulls out her rifle she aims
and fires the bullet hits the American
in the chest he is flung off the back of
SCP 682 and engulfed in a sea of SCP 610
creatures the kill Squad continues to
drive trying to put as much distance
between themselves and the SCP 610
infestation as possible but then Calvin
suddenly Slams on the break standing in
front of them is a man in a black suit
and bow tie he introduces himself as
Blackbird the fifth overseer according
to the journal his actual name is
Mortimer J Denning Von Kiker he stands
in front of the jeep with a menacing
grin you have been causing a lot of
trouble he says looking at Calvin Olivia
swings her gun around oh please my dear
that won't help you Von cnar says he
pulls out a knife and stabs himself
through the neck he falls to the ground
apparently dead there is a gust of wind
a whiff of ozone and an identical copy
and still very much alive on Kiker lands
next to his own dead body see what I
mean he says Olivia lowers her rifle
come with me I have something to show
you the Blackbird beckons seeing no
other option Calvin Olivia Adam exit the
Jeep and followed the Blackbird as they
walk the world changes around them the
desert mountains Fade Away into
Blackness and find themselves in the
near apocalyptic London oh it's good to
to be how the Blackbird says as they
emerge onto a cobblestone street you
cannot stop the overseers plans however
I can give you an alternative let's see
if any of you will take it in front of
each kill Squad member appears a door
they have an uncontrollable urge to open
their respective door and walk through
the Blackbird stands smiling as he
watches Calvin Olivia and Adam enter
each of their portals Adam enters his
door and looks around he is in Portland
his parents walk into the room in this
universe his family has been granted
Asylum Adam never has to interact with
any scps or the foundation he is free to
live a normal life from the kitchen
comes Calvin wearing an apron he is
holding a steaming pot Adam locks eyes
with Calvin who Smiles at him the
Blackbird Whispers into Adam's ear in
this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive also the man
you love loves you back you and Calvin
could be met married if you stayed here
wouldn't that be nice Olivia enters her
door she is on the deck of a yacht at
the bow sits an easel with art supplies
the man that Olivia once loved walks
across the deck towards her the
Blackbird looms over her in this reality
you didn't accidentally kill him this
could be your happily ever after
wouldn't that be nice Calvin steps
through his door he's in a grassy
clearing near a lake the Blackbird
hisses in Calvin's ear I'm giving you
with the opportunity to save your mother
this time Calvin you were just a scared
little boy but in this reality you can
be brave you can actually save your
mother from her fate no Calvin screams
this isn't real the Blackbird cackles
Calvin looks away from the lake and
towards the tree line hidden in the
shadows he can just barely make out a
hooded figure Calvin walks towards it
the Blackbird follows he is screaming at
the person in the tree line it was only
trying to help the hooded figure reaches
out and hands Calvin a metal tube he
opens it to find a set of eyeglasses
inside Calvin puts them on and turns to
look at the Blackbird he steps back in
horror the glasses have revealed the
true form of the Blackbird he is a
winged pseudo Aven monstrosity full of
Rage the mysterious hooded figure
directs Calvin to open the tube again
inside is an interdimensional fishing
line made by DR Wonder tainment and a
white whiffle ball bat Calvin grabs the
fishing line and wraps it around 05- 5's
leg the Blackbird flies into the air
trying to get away from Calvin but
Calvin wraps the other end of the
fishing line around his arm the
Blackbird begins to jump from Dimension
to Dimension trying to get rid of Calvin
they appear on the deck of SCP 455 in
sight 19 where SCP 682 walks freely in
the dead world of SCP
2935 every time they stop in a new
dimension Calvin takes the opportunity
to attack the blackbird with the bat and
it seems that he is slowly weakening the
monster they finally land at the bottom
of a deep well foundation containment
site where the dark body that is SCP 001
is contained standing in front of the
containment field is Allison sha The
Black Queen whose sole mission is to
destroy the foundation you cries the
Blackbird you are the one who's been
helping Lucien The Black Queen nods her
head yes I have been helping Calvin
Lucien to eliminate you and the other
overseers the foundation Must Fall you
are nothing you cannot stop me I am the
black king screams 0 5-5 Allison Chow
sigh she pushes a button on the panel
next to her shutting down the array
containing the dark body out of the
cloud of dust appears SCP 01 a massive
black creature who seemed to absorb all
light no stop up shrieks the Blackbird
SCP 001 does not move but the room
begins to shake the Blackbird continues
to scream as his body folds in on itself
until he is reduced to a single
superheated point and then blinks out of
existence Allison Chow then reactivates
the containment array sealing 001 away
once again I will return you to your
reality along with your friends says the
black queen but perhaps our path shall
cross again cvin Lucien there is a
bright flash of light and Calvin finds
himself on a private jet sitting next to
Olivia and Adam they are all shaken but
the Blackbird is dead 0 5-5 has been
eliminated the three members of the team
said silently still pondering What Might
Have Been if they stayed in the
alternate realities suddenly the phone
on the plane begins to ring breaking the
silence Calvin picks it up on the other
line is the fourth overseer he has
contacted Calvin to discuss Sur
surrendering to the Insurgency
unfortunately things do not always go as
planned Calvin Lucien is about to make
the most difficult and dangerous
decision of his life Aaron seagull
better known to Foundation members as 0
5-1 descends into the abyss of a Deep
Well site he exits the elevator and
peers into the optical scanner to unlock
the reinforced door inside the room is
mobile task force tow 5 Sara Aaron
seagull refers to these Immortal cyborg
clones created from the Flesh of a dead
God as his red right hand your mission
is to eliminate the traitor 05- 4 and to
find the insurgents who have been
killing the members of the overseer
Council the cyborgs stand at attention
now Aaron seagull screams the soldiers
of the red right hand March out the door
to start their mission Aaron seagull
pauses for a moment and then slams his
fist against the wall all in frustration
he has lost nine overseers to Calvin
Lucian and his kill squad team they have
been somehow overcoming the odds each
time and eliminating each overseer they
tracked down it wasn't supposed to end
this way Aaron seagull vows to kill them
all Calvin Lucian meanwhile sits on a
private jet with Adam and Olivia he had
just hung up the phone after a
conversation with 0 5-4 the overseer
known as the Ambassador wants to
surrender to the Insurgency there's a
good chance this is a trap but Calvin
has decided to meet with the Ambassador
all the same Calvin drops off Adam and
Olivia at an Insurgency base they still
haven't fully recovered from the
previous Mission with 05- 5 known as the
Blackbird before leaving though Calvin
meets with an Insurgency agent named
Sylvester Sloan who is going to join him
as support Calvin says goodbye to Adam
and Olivia then leaves with Sloan to
meet The Ambassador in South Africa
after landing at Johannesburg Airport
report Calvin and Sloan disembark and
are led to a conference room where the
Ambassador sits waiting for them Calvin
and Sloan sit across from 5-4 to discuss
his surrender the council is in shambles
says the Ambassador everything is
falling apart I want to offer my
services and information to the
Insurgency in exchange for protection
from 05- one he has lost his mind Calvin
agrees to the terms and prepares for
extraction but as they get up from the
table gunshots can be heard from down
the hall the Ambassador Eyes Open Wide
in Terror it's too late he whispers
Calvin and Sloan grab the Ambassador who
is Frozen in fear and exit the
conference room they make their way
towards their plane but the gunshots are
getting closer Calvin looks over his
shoulder to see Sam Sara pursuing them
through the terminal Calvin shoves the
Ambassador behind a table as bullets
whiz overhead Calvin and Sloan return
fire but their volley doesn't seem to
slow down the Assassins Calvin and Sloan
pull the ambassador to his feet and they
burst through through an emergency exit
onto the sunbaked tarmac where they make
a Mad Dash for the plane from behind
them a bullet rips through the chest of
Sloan the red right hand has caught up
but Calvin continues to drag the
Ambassador towards the plane they are
almost there suddenly a metallic child's
Voice blares through the airport's
external speakers the child's voice says
I want Calvin Lucien alive I have
business to settle with him the red
rightand soldiers tackle Calvin and the
Ambassador to the ground when they are
just feet away from the plane kill the
traitor the child's voice says and
Calvin can only watch helplessly as the
Ambassador is violently murdered one of
the agents turns towards Calvin and
slams his fist into Calvin's face
causing him to black out Calvin awakes
in a dark room he is unsure how much
time has passed the only light in the
room comes from a screen on the wall in
the middle of the screen is a rotating
red SCP Foundation seal a voice from
speaker speaks hello Calvin Lucien my
name is the kid I am the third overseer
you have killed all my friends and now I
will kill all of yours the door to the
room opens Calvin leans through the
doorway there is a long dimly lit
hallway the kid orders him to proceed so
they can meet face to face as Calvin
walks the kid's voice Echoes down the
hallway there once was another
see into the future but unfortunately
for him he did not have the passion
required to be an overseer that was when
I was born I was chosen by the other
overseers to have my spinal cord severed
in a way that gave me the ability of the
allseeing eye I now watch everything all
of the time I have perfect reasoning
perfect awareness and perfect
understanding Calvin gets to the end of
the corridor which opens up into a large
chamber tied up in the middle of the
room are Olivia and Adam Calvin runs to
his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at Calvin Olivia
and Adam Calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside I now sentence you all
to death the mechanical suit says as the
red right hand steps out of the shadows
and slowly walks towards the remaining
members of the kill Squad suddenly
there's a flash of light and the black
queen appears stop what are you doing
shrieks the K The Black Queen hands
Calvin the interdimensional rod and reel
he used to defeat the Blackbird Calvin
casts the rod from out of the terror in
space comes a massive multi-armed
creature known as madami gon the red
right hand engages the monster trying to
force it back into its Dimension but the
monster is too powerful he grabs the
cyborg clones and pulls them through the
tear in reality as samsara battles the
madicon Calvin frees Olivia and Adam
they make a run for the door but as they
flee one of the walls opens up to reveal
a turret the gun fires and a bullet hits
Olivia directly in the head killing her
instantly no yells Calvin before Calvin
can push Adam out of the way a second
Bullet From the turret launches itself
and Adam's back Calvin and Adam slide
across the floor the kid in his
mechanical suit jumps down from the
platform above I am going to kill you
now Calvin Lucien he says in his
mechanical voice there is another flash
of light Calvin watch in front of him as
the Spear of the non-believer manifests
itself before his eyes Calvin grabs the
spear and shoves it into the kid's
machine body it easily penetrates the
armor and pins him to the wall Calvin
walks up to the exoskeleton and tears
off the outer plating revealing a tank
full of fluid within which floats a
malformed human fetus as Calvin finally
looks upon the kid's True Form he hears
the sound of mocking mechanical laughter
Calvin breaks the glass and C crushes
the kid with his bare hands as Calvin
turns from the now silent robotic body
of the kid the room begins to shake
debris raining down from above Calvin
helps Adam up and puts Olivia's lifeless
body across his shoulders what remains
of the kill Squad makes their way out of
the kids Lair outside of the foundation
site where they were being held Calvin
helps Adam lie down on the ground before
gently setting Olivia's body next to him
Adam grimaces as blood pours out of the
wound in his back Calvin reaches into
his pocket and pulls out the vial of
water from the Fountain of Youth there
are only a couple of drops left which he
pours into Adam's mouth Adam looks up at
Calvin tears filling his eyes he
whispers I love you before he passes out
from the pain the wound in his back
begins to heal instantly and Calvin
calls an Insurgency Evac team to come
pick up Adam with Adam safe Calvin picks
up Olivia and walks alone towards a
truck in the lot outside of the
foundation site he needs to finish this
once and for all he will kill the last
two overseers or he will die trying 05-
one Aaron seagull arrives at where the
Tigris and Euphrates rivers meet the
Garden of Eden he is in a frenzy due to
the assassinations of all the other
overseers besides himself and the
Nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomal entity with a flaming
sword but Aaron seagull has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
Guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at Adam who rolls out of the way
and in a Flash takes out a Scranton
reality anchor he slams The Anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
Shimmer and ripple around him he watches
as the Flames from the gate Guardian
Sword seem to absorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that is left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated Aaron Sprints into the garden
he searches the garden for 0 5-2 but
can't find her anywhere he finally comes
to the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the Nazarene she
has taken her own life this is her
anomalous power though she has died many
times before yet death always spared her
and brought her back but somehow he
knows this time is final Aaron drops to
his knees and screams in frustration for
all the power Aaron seagull possesses
there's nothing he can do now he sits
next to the nazar's body for hours
hoping that she might wake up or that he
will to find that this was all a dream
after sitting next to her cold body for
some time he notices something in her
Snowy White Hand it's a note in it the
nazarine explains that she was the one
who gave the vials from the fountain to
Calvin Lucian and that she is the one
who made the spear appear before him
that he used to kill the kid she
explained that while she died many times
and death always brought her back each
time she felt less and less like herself
less and less like Dr Sophia light she
hoped that maybe if things ended up like
this it would give Aaron the chance to
walk away and live the life that they
might have been able to have together
but she knows deep down that Aaron's
fade is to meet Calvin and finish things
once and for all Aaron seagull screams
in Rage clutching the node in his hand
he tries to summon death but no one
comes Aaron seagull is alone he stands
up and walks deeper into the garden he
walks until he reaches a spot where even
God's light does not reach in this
desolate land is an impact crater where
Lucifer star of the morning had fallen
in the middle of the crater lies
Lucifer's sword Aaron seagull descends
into the hole and picks up the sword he
turns and exits the Garden of Eden Aaron
seagull has only one mission in life now
to kill Calvin Lucien Calvin reads the
final entry of the journal in it the
author warns that although he hopes the
information contained within the journal
is helpful he hopes the reader does not
try to use it the words written on the
final page are this information will
only lead you to a devastating end
Calvin closes the journal and looks up
at the structure in front of him he is
made it to sight 01 he had left Olivia's
body in a cave nearby promising to her
that he would make this right he now
walks up to the massive doors and places
his hand on the knotted wood the doors
slowly Creek open Calvin pauses for a
moment and looks behind him at the
Setting Sun he enters sight 01 where he
knows oh 5-1 is where Aaron seagull
Waits inside the main hall Calvin sees a
giant doorway in the shape of the SCP
Foundation seal with artistic depictions
of certain scps that he instinctively
knows are special in some way standing
next to the doorway is a 2 m tall man in
what looks to be a futuristic suit
Calvin approaches and asks who this
giant man is he responds that his name
is purpose the red right hand he is the
guardian of 5-1 and None Shall enter the
sanctum until he returns he isn't here
asked Calvin no purpose responds he is
and with that he steps aside and lets
Calvin pass through the doorway the
doorway leads into a large room where
screens on the wall flash to life
depicting moments from Calvin's Journey
documenting his entire Quest had he been
in control at all or was this all a
setup to lead him to this moment as he
walks forward he finally sees him
sitting at a table in the middle of the
room is Aaron seagull Euro 5-1 Calvin
asks Aaron the man responds my name is
Aaron Calvin asks about the location of
the second overseer the Nazarene but 0
5-1 doesn't respond without needing any
more information Calvin pulls out his
sidearm and in a Flash fires off five
shots the bullets stopped in the air
inches from Air
before dissolving in a flash of light
Calvin should have known it wouldn't be
this easy stand up Aaron seagull Calvin
calls up as he holsters his gun let's
finish it Calvin pulled the Spear of the
non-believer from his back but Aaron's
only response was to
laugh you don't even know why you're
here Aaron said Calvin calls back I'm
here to kill you because when I do I
kill the foundation because when you're
gone the universe can finally heal your
life like me Calvin Lucien we are both
men driven by our own convictions
regardless of the outcome it would seem
Fate has brought us together now either
your convictions will be broken or you
will die says Aaron seagull he then
draws Lucifer's flaming sword and lunges
towards Calvin Lucian as the two men
clash with one another their
Supernatural weapons begin to destroy
the room around them Furniture is
shattered video screens are obliterated
and fire spreads across the walls Aaron
catches Calvin off balance and swings
the Flaming sword across Calvin's
stomach Calvin slides back from the
impact hunching over from the pain in
his midsection he brings his head up to
see Aaron seagull running towards him
with a flaming sword high in the air
Calvin brings up the spear from his
knees he leans back and launches it
towards Aaron seagull the spear enters
the final overseer's chest the force
from the throw pinning him against the
wall Aon seagull drops Lucifer's sword
it shatters as it hits the ground he
clutches the shaft of the spear
protruding from his sternum with both
hands 0 5-1 looks at Calvin
unbelievingly you have no idea what
you've done it was never about the
overseers Aaron seagull says spitting
out blood with every word it was
something deeper something worse Calvin
walks slowly towards Aaron seagull he
stops just in front of his final enemy
this is the way it ends Calvin says
Aaron seagull manages to whisper one
final word Sophia before his body
finally goes limp Calvin turns to see
purpose standing behind him he's dead
Calvin says half to purpose and half to
himself I killed him after a moment he
asks purpose what he really wants to
know there's a room in this facility
where someone could unmake the
foundation right take me there without
any hesitation purpos leads Calvin back
to the room with depictions of important
scps there purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops Calvin before he can
get inside I am Duty bound to tell you
purpose says that once you step inside
this elevator there is no going back
there is only one decision to be made
and it is not one that can be unmade I
know Calvin responds it's time before
stepping inside
the elevator opens a door to reveal a
room filled with bookcases and a huge
window offering a beautiful view of the
sun setting behind the mountains on the
wall are monitors depicting the ways he
had killed all of the overseers and in
the middle of the room is a large desk
with a computer Calvin sits down at the
desk and the computer comes to life the
computer prompts him to scan his
fingerprint which it accepts he's logged
in the computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all SCP
Foundation science then he sees the
single option the computer is giving him
terminate Calvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button the SCP Foundation will be no
more his finger is millimet from the
button when the phone rings Calvin
hadn't even noticed that there was a
phone on the desk Calvin stares at it
for a moment then picks it up hello he
says the voice on the other line
responds hello Calvin Lucien my name is
the administrator I've been following
your work for some time now and I must
say I am impressed I have just been
informed that you have completed your
mission congratulations are in order
what the hell are you talking about
Calvin asks please listen says the voice
on the other line the man you just
killed was once in the same exact
position you are in now granted it was a
very long time ago but Aaron seagull
originally was trying to destroy destroy
the foundation that was until I
convinced him otherwise and now like
Aaron seagull you will become the new
head of the foundation like hell I will
yells Calvin I could hang up and walk
away right now and be done with all this
you could continues the administrator
but if no one is in charge of the SCP
Foundation millions of people will die
if not billions and then nobody would be
there to manage what comes after there
is silence from Calvin that's what I
thought says the administrator I look
forward to working with you Calvin
Lucian or should I say
05- one the line goes
dead the arabor cycle one of the biggest
most legendary series of entries in the
history of the SCP Foundation we've
covered the events of this SCP 001 epic
in six videos which we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborous cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that I
can feel almost like an anomally itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
origin of the broken God the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or Calvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the 05 Council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from from the trees but worry not
because that's exactly why we're here
today we're going to step back and look
at this anomalous Odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
story lines the children the broken God
atonement and the way it ends one big
cycle as with anything involving the SCP
Foundation there's always going to be an
element of personal interpretation but
now that we've gone through the whole
cycle we think it's worth adding adding
r two sense to the proceedings so let's
start broad a question you've probably
been wondering is what do the words or
boros cycle actually mean and what is
their significance to the four stories
within while the spelling can differ
orboros refers to the ancient symbol of
a snake or dragon eating its own tail
forming a circle a direct connection to
the concept of Cycles the arbar symbol
has existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient Egyptians to the
ancient Greeks to Modern Gnostic
Traditions it's often used in alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the orborous cycle
is probably already noticing some
similarities Cycles are a common theme
in all of these Works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and often
times those who go out on a quest to
destroy something end up becoming what
they wish to destroy in the first place
in a cycle there is no true end and no
true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this Tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as the
kingdom of abdon this nasty Group which
came from the Sahara Desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
threw at them and were able to straight
up vaporize anyone who got too close if
the kingdom was able to amass enough
power it could spell the end of the
foundation and even the subjugation of
the human race enter 05- one a
reoccurring character in the ororo cycle
this outside the box thinker put all his
chips on the twins of God project
designated SCP 001 like many anomalies
before and after it this project would
Infuse a human being with Godlike Powers
but it was a power so great that it
seemed to kill anyone who attempted to
accept it needless to say this was a
major bummer for 0 5-1 but through
Relentless human experimentation even
sacrificing the population of entire
towns to the project he eventually came
up with a solution a horrifying solution
but a solution nonetheless he found that
a group of nine children with ages
varying from 4 to 11 could act as a
human conduit for 001's power and as a
result it could be a weapon capable of
turning the tide against the kingdom of
abdon during the testing phase though it
seemed like 0 5-1 went a little mad with
power he vaporized an entire church of
the broken God place of worship and used
the power of the children to wipe a few
others off the map at his own discretion
his abuses of power got so flagrant that
the administrator himself was called in
to get a handle on the situation and
surprise surprise
05-12 before disappearing himself
shortly afterwards in the end the
children were deemed too dangerous to to
be practical both because of their
anomalous powers and from the level of
ambient radiation they put out all nine
were locked in radiation proof boxes and
buried in the desert though they each
show signs of life to this day while
this may seem disconnected from the rest
of the series it actually establishes
some of the most important reoccurring
themes and ideas of the cycle as a whole
namely the foundation messing with
reality and Performing horrific acts to
achieve their goals the corruption of
the 05 Council and the fact that these
Grand attempts to change or save the
world often blow up in everyone's Faces
Sometimes literally we also have the
introduction and apparent death of the
mysterious administrator but trust us
all Is Not What It Seems with this one
the ripple effect beginning here will
affect everything going forward next the
broken God this tells the chaotic story
of a magical Clockwork box which is
worshiped by the church of the broken
God as a conduit to their deity and
eventually becomes an all devouring
mechanical Kaiju the Beast soon dubed
SCP 001 devoured and consumed all the
metal around it slowly becoming larger
and more destructive if the foundation
didn't take it out before it reached
critical mass they'd be going toe-to-toe
with a Bonafide God a fight they really
weren't sure they could win thankfully
and with a little anomalous help from
SCP
2399 the foundation was able to destroy
the anomaly They removed its Clockwork
hard from the wreckage and contained the
anomal scrap that once comprised its
destructive body however the foundation
soon realized that you just can't keep a
good god down the Clockwork heart
eventually evaded Foundation containment
while being shipped to a secondary
location and instead ended up in a small
town here it began to influence the
minds of the residents into more
subservient broken God cultists intent
on building him back up to his former
glory it'd be easy to Discount the
broken God as an outlier seeing as the
foundation came out looking much much
better here than they do in any of the
other or borus Tales but when you look
carefully its place in the overall cycle
is clear the entry ends the way it
begins with the heart of the broken God
influencing humans to carry out its
bidding the foundation had to intervene
in between these two instances but in
the end there was no net loss to the
broken God itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the SCP
Foundation speaking of major anomalous
threats now it's time for part three of
the or borus cycle atonement once again
we start off with the foundation
meddling with Cosmic scale Powers with
the creation of the area 11 Petri Cal
Fontaine spatial stabilization array try
saying that three times fast that was a
machine so powerful it was capable of
creating a singularity though what it
actually ended up doing was turning Dr
Calvin desmat into an Abomination more
specifically into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole whose
Powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious Dr Manhattan from
Watchman this new entity dubbed SCP 001
presented a grim prophecy and an ominous
offer he told the 05 Council that
anomalies were leaking into their
Universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the Multiverse
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats unsurprisingly it
was 05- one that was most interested in
this offer so much so that he held a
vote and murdered everyone who voted
against the decision to release as CP
001 having built his consensus among the
survivors on the council 0 5-1 let SCP
001 out unsurprisingly this turned out
to be a terrible decision as one of his
first acts upon being freed was to kill
the members of the 05 Council that had
just voted to release 001 saying that
they themselves were anomalous and
needed to be purged to atone for their
past sins the only Survivor was a member
of the council who abstained from the
vote who was able to Recon SCP 001
inside the petrica Fontaine array for
now once again the Thematic connections
to the rest of the ororo cycle is clear
we have a world-ending anomaly held off
but only temporarily buying time before
the cycle inevitably continues we have
the foundation abusing its power and
signing off on the death of countless
people in other dimensions and of course
the 05 Council stepped out of their
bounds and actively warped reality just
like they had with the children before
their chickens truly come home to roost
though in the final part of the cycle
appropriately named the way it ends this
piece Chronicles the story of Calvin
Lucien and the kill Squad an elite group
of four chaos Insurgency Soldiers with
one goal assassinating the entire 05
Council 13 of the most powerful people
in the world why because they've been
messing with reality itself time and
time again and it's getting to the point
that their selfish meddling could
finally destroy everything and given
that we've already seen it happen with
the children and the entity that Dr
Calvin desmit became it's hard to
disagree with them what follows is one
of the longest and most complicated
tales in all of the foundation as the
kill Squad systematically encounters and
kills each insane anomalous member of
the 05 Council in order to do this they
need to make deals with death itself
fight giant serpents cross Dimensions
deal with SCP 610 and SCP 682
containment breaches and and go
toe-to-toe with samsara arguably the
foundation's deadliest mobile task force
a number of other insane things happen
along the way like 05- one murdering the
gate Guardian with the Scranton reality
anchor and the black queen the most
prominent member of the Serpent's hand
helping our heroes defeat more overseers
in the end Calvin Lucien despite losing
almost everything Reigns victorious in
the final battle using the Spear of the
non-believer a weapon so powerful it can
kill God
Calvin managed to finally kill the Top
member of the overseers 05- one with the
05 Council destroyed Calvin set about
completing his final task destroying the
entire SCP Foundation but that didn't
happen instead he was contacted by a
mysterious and immensely powerful being
known as the administrator who gave him
some frightening news he just been hired
by the SCP Foundation to be their new
05- one this was where our last video in
the orboros series left us what happens
next you may ask how does Calvin respond
to this offer he seemingly can't refuse
in this case it seems that the
administrator of being so completely
tied to the nature of the foundation
itself is SCP 001 and while it seemed
that the overseers were mad with power
they were actually always there to keep
the administrator in check Aaron seagler
the 05- one that Calvin had just killed
was doing the exact same thing Calvin
was doing when he became 05- one trying
to destroy the foundation but the
foundation and the administrator cannot
be beaten they can only be joined and
that's exactly what Calvin did becoming
the new 05- one turning his back on the
chaos Insurgency and rebuilding the rest
of the council and the foundation in his
own image Insurgency members who were
once his allies vowed revenge for this
betrayal perhaps suggesting that history
would go on to repeat itself once more
in the future because at the end of the
day that's what the ororo cycle really
is the reoccurring threat and the
changing of the guards that accompanies
it there will always be a foundation
there will always be an administrator
there will always be an 05 Council
nothing starts nothing ends all that
ever changes are the names and faces
involved whether it's Calvin Lucien or
Aaron seagler the wheel keeps turning
the snake devour its own tail the aorus
cycle is and forever will be Eternal now
go check out our full piece by piece
breakdown on the orboros cycle starting
with SCP 001 the children and then check
out SCP 5000 y the full story
compilation just in case we haven't
blown your mind enough for one day